- There's always that thing,
everyone knows that crime
is really low in Japan,
but when shit happens in Japan,
it's from like zero to 100.
It's like, I'm going to burn
(people screaming)
everyone alive and post it on 2chan,
just 'cause I feel like it.
(upbeat music)
- I'm gonna do an impression
of Garnt 'cause I'm a guest.
Hello, welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste Podcase.
- Really, that was your
impression of me, well, Joey.
- You really, cut up
the Trash Taste Podcase.
- You gotta pull your thing up to here.
- Oh, yeah let me pull it.
Hello welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste Podcase.
The show where we talk about food,
shitting and occasionally anime.
- Oh my God!
- I'm your host for today not Garnt.
And with me is Garnt
and the other not Garnt.
And I'm a guest, I mean, I'm a host.
We're the guest.
- You can tell this is the first time
Joey's hosting our guests
now, "I'm the guest guys."
- I'm the guest.
I'm the host with the guest
and the guest is Aki, hello.
- Hi, I'm Agnes.
How are you guys doing?
- That's your name?
- Yeah, it is.
- The long awaited.
- Is this a main reveal.
- It is, yeah.
- It's not really reveal.
You can look me up on Wikipedia,
it's like right there.
- Why'd you have to flex it?
You have a Wikipedia right off the bat.
- You have one too.
- I don't.
- I have the YouTube-
- You have the famous birthdays.
- What does that mean?
- Famous birthdays are
a plague on the earth.
They just keep fucking emailing you,
asking you for information.
- Yeah, and also half of that info
is like kind of not correct.
Yeah, it's pretty wrong.
- I think I had to email
them back like three times
'cause they kept getting
my birthday wrong.
- I think there's like a Wiki YouTube.
- Like the one thing
you shouldn't get wrong.
I think is birthdays.
I think it was your birthday.
- I know that there's like a Wiki YouTube,
and that is more like-
- That's also a play.
Yeah, that one's the most
inaccurate Wiki of all time.
- There's this one
called like celeb dating.
Have you seen this one?
- [All] No.
This one has it like-
- Wait, I think this one
just randomly takes it
and then it will be like dating
and it will be like,
summarize if you're dating
and if you're married, but
they have no information.
So everything's just like unknown.
- Speculation.
Unknown, unknown.
- [Aki] Oh my God!
- It would be like,
CDawg VA was last spotted
dating at this time
and it's like 2014.
- Wow.
- Unless you're dating another YouTuber.
- It's kind of creepy, to see how deep,
some of these people really
look back into your photos
and then that like, that's who you are.
But they don't even take into
account that there's been
literally so much time between this photo
and who you are.
- That's the other thing I
hate about famous birthdays,
is that they use photos from like 2012.
- [All] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's just like,
"Oh yeah, if I go look up this person now,
"they're gonna look exactly like this."
And you realize you look
like an eight year old photo.
- I think like on YouTube Wiki,
they even have like your top 10 friends,
they've decided like, "Oh,
I'll keep this photo."
Yeah that shit, it's
actually to fuck you with.
And then like, sometimes
I'll put some where I'm like,
I haven't even talked to
that person since like...
I don't know, like 2011.
- There's two types of
YouTubers who collab often.
That's people who only
interact through the collab
and people who interact
all the time outside
of the collab and
occasionally in the collab .
- We YouTubers, we don't have friends
outside of YouTube at all.
- It Depends on how you meet,
if they like to collab a lot
and how they like to do
that for YouTube friendship.
- Like, I recently went to an event
with like people who had
nothing to do with YouTube
and it was just kind
of refreshing actually
just to talk to people who are just-
Doing normal jobs.
- Garnt discovers people
outside of the internet exist.
- It's like "Wait, there are
people that aren't YouTubers?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- On YouTube and have nothing
to do with the anime industry.
'Cause now that like...
It's weird because now that our hobby
has turned into our jobs,
we naturally socialize with
people who are just also
to do with our job because
that's our hobbies.
So, it was weird talking to people
who were just like working, walk-
- So, TLDR you went to a bar.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Place with normies, "Guys
they are pretty cool."
- They exist.
- Yeah, like I have a
whole part of my life
that has literally nothing to do
with like YouTube or anything.
Why are my fucking earring
just fell off (laughs).
But anyways, so I'm gonna
just try and get that.
But there's like a whole part of my life
that has nothing to do with-
- Like I could say-
- Fucking.
- Outside of your earring falling down.
I think pretty one of the
more private YouTubers
that I have met.
- I like how we just went straight into it
and you didn't even introduce yourself.
- And maybe you should explain it.
- We know everything.
- They know you, but go on, go ahead.
- Why don't you-
- Just in case for the 1%
who don't know who you are.
What your relationships
are, and who you are.
- Oh gosh, where should I even begin?
- If you had to explain
to someone at the bar,
what your channel is
about and what you do.
- Oh man, like-
- Pretend you're talking to a normie.
- Yeah, pretend your
talking to a normie, yeah.
- I actually like just hang
out with mostly normies
outside of just YouTube and whenever...
like someone who doesn't know who I am,
when they ask, "Oh, what do you do?"
I literally just say, "I work from home."
It's just the easiest thing to say,
'cause the moment that I say that,
I'm a YouTuber or maybe you
guys have like had this,
but I just feel that just
opens so many doors of like-
- But that means nothing in 2020,
'cause everyone's working at home now.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, I'm just like,
"I do like marketing."
I try to pick the-
- I do marketing.
- I do, (laughs).
- That's basically how I
started explaining my job
to my parents, the first
time I started doing it,
I had to tell my grandma
that I'm a comedian.
It's just like, "Oh, I know those."
- And then I do have like those moments
where I say that I'm a YouTuber.
And then I just go into
the details of all of that.
- What your YouTube channel about?
- My YouTube channel, honestly,
people have just said,
she's not on anime channel anymore.
Or she's still in anime channel.
Honestly, I don't even-
- We should get into that later though,
into all of that stuff, I think.
- What would you call yourself?
- I'm just more of like
a no Otaku channel.
I'm just someone that lives in Japan
that just shares their life
and what they like to do here.
But I don't know,
it's weird because I still
don't really know what I am
because I used to call
myself just anime YouTube,
but then like I'm too J blog to be anime,
but then I'm too anime to be J blog.
So I just thought, "Oh, Otaku channel,
"that's probably the easiest thing."
- Who needs labels, I
don't really give a shit.
- Yeah, I'm just Otaku dearest.
- I feel Coal is in the
same realm though, right?
It's like-
- Yeah, pretty much.
- People call me anime
on YouTube and I'm like,
"Never have I talked about anime."
- I mean we both do stuff around Japan.
And it's just like...
I don't know, I feel like as an anime fan,
I do all these other things in Japan
because when you like anime,
it just puts Japan in front of you.
And then it just puts like
all of these other things.
So, that's why I'm okay
with talking about...
I don't know, just Japanese
products or just...
When I blew up,
I talked about Vocaloid
because I always just thought,
"Even though it's not an
anime, it's just something,
"every anime fan knew."
It just somehow made its way.
- It's coming just like the weed culture.
- Yeah, yeah essentially.
- I feel like you don't
need to know anything
about anime to watch my content,
but I feel like you get
a lot more out of it,
if you are to that culture and
that kind of humor, I guess.
- I feel there's a lot
more like quote unquote,
unachievers who are kind of
going in that direction too.
Like, I'd say I'm going in that direction.
- I think that's where
most anime YouTube is going
because anime content, is
just not performing well
'cause not performing as well.
- Yeah, as it was there.
Like you can't make like a 30 minutes-
- I think this season's been
really good for anime content,
but for the past year it was pretty rough.
- Like 2020 and 2019 was
really rough for anime content.
- And it's funny, 'cause I feel like,
it's really just the
hype that attack on title
that has brought that.
That has just reminded people,
"Oh yeah, animate exists
guys, anime actually exists."
And that kind of trickles
down to everything else.
- But like you can't
make like a 20, 30 minute
analysis video on some seasonal show
that's not the biggest one now,
and get half as many views.
- I never even really
watched them too much
in the first place.
I just kind of watched
stuff, and that's why like-
- Because you went to anime
conventions and stuff.
- Yeah, I went to anime but I was a plub,
I just watched shit,
but I don't actually
like think that deeply,
which is weird because like in
the beginning of my YouTube,
I used to do a lot more analytical stuff.
And one of them, I think is
like your favorite series
that I dropped a long time ago.
- "Everything You Didn't
Know About", right?
- Yeah, that one was pretty fun.
That's when I did like some detective work
going into an anime of like
what every reference meant.
My favorite ones though.
- That got so oversaturated on YouTube.
- It did, eventually it did.
- 107 things you need
to know about Naruto.
- No, no, it was more like,
"A hundred things you
didn't know about Naruto,"
but like 97 of them really obvious.
- I think it was like the
Vocaloid videos that popped up
and like the Vocaloid,
I think Ghibli videos
that popped up originally.
- This literally just one Ghibli video.
And I remember like there's so...
I don't know why the fuck that blew up,
but I know also Vocaloid.
What's funny, is that the Vocaloid video,
the first one that went up,
I originally was not going to post that
'cause I just thought, "Oh
no, I'm just going over
"like Vocaloid songs, who cares."
But then the file almost crashed
like the night that I
was going to upload that,
but then luckily enough,
there's auto-save stuff.
So, I went through like
all these fucking files,
I was like, "Please tell me
that you saved this somewhere."
And I just uploaded it,
and then the next morning,
actually within that week,
then it started to blow up.
And I remember,
we were still really
early in our friendship.
And I think when I blew up,
I got in a call with you.
I wanted to like vomit.
At like the numbers that were growing
'cause I didn't know how to handle it.
- Yeah because you were getting like...
I think it was like a hundred
K a week or something,
something ridiculous like that.
- How did you guys even meet?
'Cause I don't think you've
ever like told the story.
- We have, but like-
- I pretty forgot.
- Oh no, it's okay.
So let's see, it was like...
I don't think I was even at
a thousand subscribers, but-
- More like 800 I think, 700 subscribers.
- Okay, so I was looking for
other YouTubers to talk to.
So the last time I was on YouTube,
it was under another name,
it was called school girl, 101.
(all laughing)
- Amazing, why didn't you stick with that?
- Okay, no, I will tell-
- The anime man and School Girl 101.
- This will all wrap up
too when I meet Joey.
So when I was like 12 or 13,
when YouTube was first starting,
I had like schoolgirl 101
and I used to upload a lot of AMVs.
I loved making AMVs and it was like,
a community in itself,
animemusicvideos.org,
is anyone here old enough to remember?
You know that?
- Of course, of course.
- Oh, Garnt is in that yard.
I think Connor and I were a
little too young for that year.
- Oh yeah, yeah, oh my God, yeah.
So, I was that website
was religious to me,
so I used to upload that stuff.
And this is before copyright music
and any of that was a thing, so it was-
- Did you put Lincoln
park and shit like that?
- I absolutely fucking did.
(all laughing)
- The amount of times I've
watched the one big upload
of "AMV Hell 3",
or that was uploaded to YouTube
was just like uncountable.
- Remember we used to
call compilations, cracks.
- Yeah, I remember that.
(Aki laughing)
- Dude, oh my God, I remember that.
So yeah, no, I was uploading
AMVs and then I dwelled into...
I don't know how, but
somehow in my deep searching
of anime related stuff, I
found visual novel openings,
but I couldn't download visual novels
'cause they were really
strictly just in Japan,
- And ever fucking impulsive
to download back then too.
But the openings were
available on YouTube,
which I still have those saved
on my current account today, in private.
So then, I found all these websites
and I uploaded all of the
opening songs on that.
And then they were all like
Hentai, so I got banned.
- So uploaded Hentai
on to School Girl 101?
- Yeah I did.
- Why did you pick the
name School Girl 101?
- I promise it was not nothing perverted.
I thought it just sounded cool.
And I was watching "Zoe
101", and I went to school.
(all laughing)
- I was trying to figure
out where the 101 came from.
- 'Cause I was watching Zoe 101 back then
and I was a school girl (laughs).
But when I look back, I'm like, "Fuck."
- I think one of my names was like,
X-Box best corner or something.
'Cause I'm the best in X-Box.
- Yeah, no the cringer username, honestly-
- That's like the same
logic I came up with.
- Honestly, I'm glad that, that
YouTube account got banned,
but I'm kind of sad, all those AMVs
just went down, like the shit got banned.
- All those Lincoln Parks.
- I know it was like evanescence and...
I definitely went down that route.
- Okay, so you are School Girl 101?
- Yeah, that all went away.
And then I just watched
YouTube from behind the scenes.
Then one day, I decided
I wanted to do YouTube.
I wasn't even at a thousand subs.
And because I was so close
in that AMV community,
I didn't know where anyone was anymore.
So I was like, let me
get in another community.
Joey was the first one that I found
that was closest to my age.
And I thought that,
he was really funny when
he was playing NekoPara.
So the very first mistake-
- I bet he was so fun.
(indistinct chatter)
- I loved it.
(all laughing)
Watched it all the time.
- It was like put in one
more time, put it on.
- I loved that one.
- What a classic.
- It wasn't even like the first video
of that NekoPara series.
But when I was watching it,
I just thought that you were really funny.
So I was like, is
YouTube DM still a thing,
I've been gone a long time.
- YouTube Dms.
- That's how far back we're talking.
- We are going far back now.
- Legit, so, I messaged
him on YouTube and I said-
- How many subs did
Joey have at this time-
- Oh, not even like 10 K I think.
- Oh, wow!
- Yeah, I maybe 20, 30-
- We were both very small.
- No, I think I was like 20, 30K maybe?
- So Joey dated a fan?
(all laughing)
- No, I messaged him-
- Joey, the anime man exposed.
- Yeah but like, look.
Okay, so I'm from a part of YouTube
where subscribers weren't
really that big of a thing.
- Anything under like around
that size, like a thousand.
- It would be a bit of a different story,
if I had like 3 million and she had 800.
- [All] Yeah.
- I mean like it's whatever.
But so, I sent him a message and I said...
I called you anime man.
And I was like-
(all laughing)
So fucking weird, but said,
"Hi anime Man, I saw your NekoPara video,
"thought you were hilarious.
"Do you like dogens?
"If you want, let's read one together."
- No, you found this fucking
pokemon dogen of god of war.
- Yeah and I just was like-
- And was like, "We should
read it on camera together."
And I was like, "All right."
So I got on a call with her.
- No, no, no, hold on.
But there was something in between.
But because it was YouTube DMS,
I was not expecting a reply.
'Cause I was like...
I think it was like 2014, 15.
Times have changed, but my
mind was so all the way back,
but literally in an hour,
you replied back to me
and you told me that like later on,
that you had not really
looked at your YouTube DMS
until that night, and
I was at the very top.
And had you not seen it that night,
this wouldn't have happened.
- It was purely coincidentally.
- Yeah, and then after that...
- 'Cause who the fuck went
through their YouTube DMs.
- Exactly, YouTube got rid of it.
I think YouTube got rid of it now, right?
You can't-
- I think it still
technically exists somewhere.
- Yeah, I have tried to look.
- Cause if not, they could
have completely buried it.
- So, I don't have-
- You don't have an archive.
- No, I know.
- That's so sad.
- I don't know, maybe-
- I don't know if I want to, to be honest.
I don't wanna see a message
of, "Hello anime man."
(all laughing)
- I mean, that's the
beginnings there, right?
- No but there is a video on his channel
of where I still called him anime man.
It's when we were
playing orange juice 100-
- Some shitty anime game.
- No, its called orange
juice 100% or something.
I'm doing it for them,
like what was it called?
- Oh, I don't want them
to look at the video.
(all laughing)
- So, I'm trying to be inconspicuous,
it's some shitty anime game.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I don't know which one I'm talking about.
- (indistinct) Don't put it
on the screen, I swear to God.
- So we were just really good friends
for like a couple of years.
And then he got trapped in Canada and-
- You got explain why I
got trapped in Canada?
You're not gonna just say that.
- Because then he.
- I lost my passport.
- I remember he told the story.
- He lost his passport,
he was really stressed,
but I had no idea that you were in Canada,
but this was like,
we had been friends for a long time
and we had been calling so frequently.
I was like, "I'm gonna
just tell him, I like him.
"I don't even care, I'm
gonna just get in the call."
And that was like, you
were still at your hotel,
stressed out of your mind, I
was like, "I really like you."
- And did, "Now is not the
time, I lost my passport."
- Was there a process
where you thought about
this is the right time to tell him?
Or were you just like, "He's
fuck out of his mind, fuck it!"
- I didn't know that he was in Canada.
I didn't know that he was trapped there.
I didn't know that you were
like going through other shit.
I was like, "I'ma just
tell him, uh whatever."
(all laughing)
- What did you think?
- I hadn't eaten in like two days.
And the first thing I get is,
"I like you," from Aki
Dearest and I was like,
there's a Danny's down road
and like I'm fucking starving.
- No but then, you know, what's funny?
You were so disoriented.
And also like...
So, I don't know if anyone knows this,
but I'm Joey's first girlfriend,
like real girlfriend.
- Like proper girlfriend.
- Yeah proper girlfriend he had...
you had seen some other people
in the past past, but...
- But it was like high
school relationships,
I don't count those.
- Yeah, yeah, so what was funny,
is I think he was so dense.
Like I literally said the
words, I like you a lot.
And then he said,
"Wait, are you saying what
I think you're saying?"
And then I said, "I think I said it."
(Aki laughing)
- I am dead ass that dense,
like heroin protagonists.
- Say you like me, I don't
know what are you saying.
- What are you trying to say right now?
- And I was like, "I think I said it'.
(all laughing)
Yeah, but from there actually,
I think we talked for like
10 or 15 hours that day.
- Yeah, 'cause I had nothing else to do.
'Cause I was in my fucking
Toronto hotel room.
- So, I was just a liar bell.
That was a special moment for me.
- I miss being like 19
and just being able to spend
all day on a Skype call.
- Yeah, right.
- What the fuck (mimicking sobs).
- We used to be able to
do that all the time.
And it was like with that group
of friends where it's like,
it didn't matter if nobody
talked, like you were just on it.
- Like, what's the longest
Skype call you guys
have ever been in?
- Together or just ever?
- Just in general.
- I think it was the one with her
where I was in a Skype call
for like 12 hours or something?
- Yeah, 12 hours, and then after that,
I think one time came,
when you finally got back to Australia
and then we gave it time to think,
and we were both blowing up
around like the same time.
- You mean our channels were, not us.
- Yeah, yeah, sorry, sorry.
(all laughing)
- I can't hear the word blowing up
without thinking about that meme,
of where that guy's like,
"When I blow up, I don't know nobody.
(all laughing)
sorry, sorry.
- Because...
No it's cool.
And then when our careers
were like finally taking off,
we just kind of got in a talk and said,
"This isn't going to
work and we're too busy."
And I don't know I feel like we were both-
- Well, it was also because
I was in my last year
of uni at the time.
And I was stressed out of my
fucking mind because I'm like,
"If I don't knuckle down on this shit,
"I'm not gonna graduate."
- I've been playing
Kolbe's party 18 hours.
I can't, be doing free translations
for Kolbe's party visual novel,
like I gotta fucking knuckle down.
So, I was like, at that point,
I not only like ghosted you,
I ghosted everyone on YouTube
for like three months.
- Last year of uni do be like that.
- And then in the meanwhile,
I was just kind of my doing my own thing.
Fast forward though,
AX comes around and then we
both messaged each other.
And I think there's also
my Samurai bio video
had just come out that day,
and that's when you DM'd me.
- Good old Samurai bio,
you remember that shit?
- I guess we've just gotten
like this private talk,
but I was just like, okay.
Yeah, we're going to AX.
I'll see you there,
and so we met and yeah.
- That was AX 2016?
- I think so, yeah.
- That was like...
I think watching you guys at
AX just before you even like...
did we speak at that point?
I think so.
- We spoke, but we hadn't met.
- I think so, that was when
I was like, I don't care.
I'm going to AX next year.
I felt so left out,
seeing how much fun it was that the AX.
- Was that at the AX I first met you
or was that the AX before that?
- Before, I think.
- It was the AX, was it before?
God I don't remember.
- I can't remember.
- It might've been the one...
No, it might've been
that AX, it was that AX.
It was the first time we met.
- 'Cause I think my first one was 2017 AX.
- So mine was 2015, I think 2016?
- 'Cause you've been
a few times before me.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Yeah, 2016 was the first
year I met you and Jeff.
- Yeah that's right.
- But I think I'd gone to one before that.
I don't know if anyone else had gone?
- No, 2016 was the first one.
- I've gone to AX like every
year, since I was like 13.
- I'm so jealous.
- So you've seen the
scene evolve over time.
- It's honestly just been so
fucking great, like it's...
- What was the first year
you went, like what year?
- I don't even know.
I actually, I-
- Do you remember how
old you were, roughly?
- I was maybe almost 14 or 15.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
Yeah, I was 14 or 15, my first.
- That's 2013.
- Not even, that was like 2010.
- That was back then where
like the line was big,
but it went by fast, like
day zero wasn't a problem.
Now seeing it nowadays,
like I love day zero,
like I don't even want.
- Line con.
- Yeah, yeah, line con basically,
so yeah, I know it's been crazy to see
just the progression of things.
And I used to watch
videos of AX back in 2007.
And if you look at any blogs
of AX of 2007, they will say,
"Oh my God, it's like, so packed here."
Literally, It's just like empty.
- Its like 3000 people.
- Yeah, but that was a lot back then.
- It's the Pedro De Flores
videos that you watched
because I watched exactly the same thing.
'Cause I remember back in-
- Oh, sorry who is this?
- Oh, sorry no, go for it.
- Okay, so it's basically a guy
who seemed to be very
influenced by Kassem G.
like some, you know,
the good old Kassem G.
- Old YouTubers.
- Old YouTubers but what
he would basically do,
is he would go around AX
every year and just vlog in
and do interviews.
And it's like in the Kasem
G kind of style, and me-
- So it was like trying to put them out
to be kind of more stupid.
- Yeah, exactly.
And me as a Wiebe, growing up
in like the mid two thousands,
never been to a convention in my life.
And especially the UKC.
- Well in UK, I mean what do we have.
- Especially in the UK
scene, seeing these vlogs,
this was like Mecca to me.
I remember watching these
vlogs and I remember thinking,
"I'm gonna be there one day,
I'm gonna be there one day."
- It was legit.
Like the greatest thing I
had ever seen in my life.
Like, okay, by the way,
if you guys ever wanna look
at him Pedro De Flores,
I don't know if you were
still around watching this,
but it's like P-E, P-E-E.
- P-E-D-
- It will be on screen.
- P, literally P-D-F-L-O, I think.
- Looking at the AX vlogs, I was like,
"This is blowing my fucking mind."
- I think one thing I was
always jealous of Americans,
is that like, it seems they just accept
any side of weird culture.
- Yeah.
And then in the UK, and probably
Australia as well, right?
It felt that like,
if you were into stuff that
wasn't like super normal,
it felt like everyone
treats you like weird.
- I mean AX brought money and money talks.
- But watching like being
from the UK or Australia,
watching American conventions
or seeing just the way they
treat nerd culture in general,
and I was always so jealous,
is one of the reasons why I always wanted
to move to the U.S.
I mean, obviously now,
its very different advice.
- Kids have it easy.
- I didn't give a shit back then.
I was like, I'll go anywhere.
Right, because back then, to me,
America was like this
whole like mystical place.
And than obviously now.
- Mystical place?
- It was, it was like
a place where everyone
could just do what they wanted.
And like, everyone could
like whatever they wanted.
And it always like a huge place to go.
If you liked a specific thing,
there was always a big convention
of like-minded individuals.
- I think its also because...
Especially conventions like the UK,
especially like America was
just so much fucking bigger.
So there's this,
it just felt like there
was more stuff there.
- And then there was like huge nerds
and look, "Otaku is in the UK."
But because again you
were just like looked on.
- We couldn't find each other.
That was the biggest thing.
Because in America,
it seems like there was
always a place for somewhere,
wherever you wanted to belong.
And I remember looking at AX
or like all these con videos
and thinking, "Man, oh
God, I wish that was me.
"I look like I belong there."
- Oh my God, I remember
when I went to my very,
very first convention and I
just felt like this was right.
Like, I knew that this was where my heart
was supposed to be.
- I saw that too, when
I went to a convention.
I was like my people.
- Oh yeah, 'cause then it's just like,
remember back there,
'cause we could not find each
other and even in the U.S,
it was still like this, it
was more online than anything.
But when you found someone was like,
"Oh, you're like Naruto too."
Like, and then you just instantly connect.
- Well, in Australia there
wasn't even an online scene like-
- I feel almost like in America...
I don't know if this is true,
but like parents kind of
like are more accepting
of like weird hobbies for the kid.
In the UK man, my parents
would give me shit.
- My parents were like that close to-
- I would come down for dinner.
I'd be like, "Oh, it's the anime fan,
"Oh, oh okay."
- Yeah, my parents used to
be really kind of weirded out
about the fact that I liked anime,
but now, my parents are very
rare for their generation.
They love YouTubers and streamers.
They tell me shit that even
I haven't caught up to yet.
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah, they
know literally everyone.
And then, what's funny,
is I'm logged into my YouTube account also
on the one at home, back in Vegas.
The reason for that, is
because of time zones,
my mom checks to see if
I got like a content,
like copyright claim, and she
goes to my account and then...
- She, is literally your manager.
- Yeah, she claims out for me.
And then I wake up the next morning.
I was like, "Mom, did
you claim this story?"
She's like, "Yeah, I
was just looking at it."
- Meanwhile my mom's like,
"Who's your Swiss friend PPD?"
- My mom will occasionally go in.
When there's been a big
YouTube in the news.
She'll be like, "I heard
these Logan fellow,
"who was in a fight.
"I couldn't believe it."
(all laughing)
- Do you know him?
- Yeah, we're friends with Logan.
(all laughing)
- No, my parents have
definitely done their hardest
to try and like keep up with the times.
- My parents, do try but
they are just too out of it.
- My parents are also the same, yeah.
- My parents have really changed
since Trash Taste started.
'Cause that's just given them
so much content to watch.
And now it's gotten to the
point where every single clip
and every single...
Now, we have like official
and then unofficial clip streams as well.
And that's all been recommended
to her and she watches,
like way more content than I do now.
She's purely off like us, I guess.
- Yeah, my parents are kind of just like,
we don't support what you
do, you just kind of do it.
- We don't support what you
do but you do your own thing.
- No, no, my dad.
- We do not support Joey and his job.
- No, my dad's straight,
like in the Q&A that I
did, was with my dad.
My dad was straight up, like,
"I don't really like support what you do.
I just kind of let you do it."
And I'm like, "Thanks, dad."
(Joey laughing)
- The only thing about having parents
that are so in tune
with what I do, is like-
- That would annoy me.
- It would annoy me, yeah.
- Them giving me feedback
about my thumbnail.
- My dad doesn't give a
shit about what to do.
And yet he's still like,
"Yeah son, I didn't really
like that video you made,
"it's was like-"
- Same as my parents as well.
- I didn't fucking made it for you, I-
- Yeah, no, and then dude, my parents,
like they used to back
when it was like used more,
they looked at like
social blades and stuff.
Like they're very into like-
- That's like old a little too.
- I don't look at my own social way,
I don't want my parents
to tell me about it.
- My dad, he went through a point
when he was just literally
clicking and refreshing it.
And I was just like,
"Dad, this is not healthy.
"Why are you doing this, please stop."
- That's kind of cute though.
I don't know why, it's like,
"Oh, I wanna see your girl."
- Oh man, yeah.
- I occasionally get
my mom, she'll be like,
"Oh, the last video didn't do
as well as the other video."
I'm like, "Mom not everyone
can be a (indistinct), no mom."
- Don't rub it in.
- Come on, I know it did bad,
I don't need you telling me.
- My dad would sometimes
find me and be like,
"Son, last week, you only
grew like 1000 subscribers.
"Normally you grow like
2000, what's going on?
"What, is your channel dying?"
- Is your channel dying.
- Yeah, is your channel
dying, what's going on?
- My dad right now, he's
like having his own version
of like, "You winning son?"
It's more like, "Oh yeah."
"Your video doing well?"
Like, it's just every upload.
He just has the say.
- That's cute though,
I'd like to think that.
- This episode is sponsored by liquid I.V.
- Guys, you know I love drinking water,
do a plenty on the podcast,
plenty of pee breaks.
And one goal I have for
myself for the new year,
is just to stay hydrated.
And I do that
with my favorite hydration
products, liquid I.V.
- With one stick of liquid
I.V. in 16 ounces of water,
you get two to three times
the amount of hydration
as plain water, that's water optimized.
- And they have incredible
hydration flavors,
like watermelon, lemon-lime, passion fruit
and they've recently launched, strawberry.
- I like strawberry.
- I do too.
- Personally, I really like liquid I.V.
because I just like
flavored water in general.
So if I can get extra
hydration off of something,
I already enjoy in concept then, why not?
- Honestly, when you
wake up from a hangover
and sometimes you drink so much water
that the taste of water
just starts gets sickening,
this actually tastes really good.
And this would be perfect
for a hangover day.
- Honestly.
- I do like the watermelon flavor.
So I'll give them that.
- I like the watermelon flavor too.
- [Announcer] Once serving of liquid I.V.,
provides the same hydration
as drinking two to three
bottles of water alone.
And it contains five essential vitamins,
more vitamin C than an average orange
and as much potassium as a banana.
And it's healthier than
sugary sports drinks,
no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar
than an Apple.
Made with clean ingredients,
non GMO vegan and free
gluten dairy free and soy.
- So, you can grab your
strawberry liquid I.V.
or their other great
flavors in bulk nationwide
at any Costco.
And you can get 25% off
when you go to liquidiv.com
and use code TRASHTASTE at checkout.
- That's 25% of anything, when you order
and use promo code
TRASHTASTE at liquidiv.com.
Get better hydration
today at liquidiv.com,
promo code TRASHTASTE.
Back to the episode.
- Oh.
- What were we talking about?
- You said you didn't really
want to be a YouTuber.
- When?
- Did you say that?
I heard you say that.
I heard you say that, earlier on.
I mean, when I started YouTube,
I didn't intend to be a
YouTuber or anything like that.
- I don't think anyone is,
you just kind of do it.
- I don't think anyone just wakes up and-
- 'Cause I just made this video
'cause I thought I could
make this funny video
and I wanted to show my friends.
So I was like, "I'm gonna make
this for me and my friends."
And I just put it up, put
it in a nice little package
and then I thought one
and done, that's it.
- I feel that's like the
kind of secret formula
to being a successful YouTuber.
It's like people who start a
YouTube channel with the intent
of like, "Yeah, I'm gonna be
the fucking next puddy pie",
it's like it never works.
- I'm curious, like what made
you wanna do that first video?
What was your first video as well?
- That wasn't like an AMV
or anything like that.
- Oh, I remember.
I think it's still on there.
I was playing this visual
novel of a dramatical murder
and it's literally like a five minute clip
'cause it was during the final scene of me
trying to get with like a one-
- Did you have heavy breathing?
- Actually it was, it's
still on my channel
and it's me and my microphone.
I was like, "Okay guys so I
just got clear here, let's see.
"Oh my God."
It's like like me just
doing that the whole time.
- Was it like the whisper scream?
Like, "Oh my God, guys."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah because
it was like 12 minutes.
I think that made my first video,
which was like Christmas Eve.
- Were your parent in the house?
- Yeah they were.
- So I was like.
- What the fuck.
- I was super like, Minecraft YouTuber.
I'm like, "Oh my God I can't believe
"that this is happening right now."
But yeah, so that was my first one.
And then I knew I wanted to do YouTube
once I got my first paycheck.
- Right.
(all laughing)
But that's true.
- I appreciate the honesty.
It's literally with anything,
when you figure out that,
"Oh my God, I can get paid for something."
'Cause you want to do it, yeah.
So I don't know, so there was a video.
I'm not gonna say what
blow up, but what blew up,
but it blew up.
And then I got my first
paycheck and it was $300.
And I remember, I felt like-
- The big dough.
- No, no, no.
I mean, you say that by that
time, that was a lot of dough.
- That was a lot of dough.
- True, true, true.
- And what's weird is like,
this is gonna sound like really cheesy,
but I felt like I was at
a crossroad tour here,
that $300 was perfect for the
rest of my meals for college,
for the rest of the month,
or that was the perfect
amount to get lights
and a better camera.
So, I went that way and
my mom was very concerned
about the choice that I made.
But I was like, "You know what?
"This is just money from YouTube.
"So if this doesn't work, it's not like,
"it was my own money from work."
I used to work in a movie theater.
And then yeah, once that happened,
I remembered how much
I loved making videos
from the School Girl 101.
And I was like, "Fuck."
And then I just felt
like this fire going on.
And I was like, I want to do YouTube.
I knew from that point,
I wanted this to work.
I was gonna give myself a year,
to try and make this work.
So what I did and I guess
it's questionable to some,
but I told them all my friends around me
that you're not gonna see me for a year.
'Cause I want to do this.
'Cause I had a part-time job,
I was a full-time student
getting my psychology degree
and I only had time for one other thing,
and that was YouTube.
So, I did that.
And then also, I was in a relationship
and that person didn't
want me to do it at all,
and I had cut it.
Like when we had...
I tried talking it out and-
- Anyone who would stop
you from doing something
you're passionate about,
normally isn't the one for you.
- Yeah. no and I knew then and there
that YouTube was what I
wanted from that moment on.
And when he said he
didn't want me to do it,
I had no problems cutting his-
- You were like, "Bye."
- No, like it was-
- Understadable.
- Well, have a nice day.
(all laughing)
It's like, and also I mean,
it was a lot of pressure to try
and balance your relationship
out and give it a year.
I remember, I would go to
school, go straight to work.
And then, because I had
to come back at midnight
after the last showing,
then I would work sometimes
up until 7:00 AM or something.
- I think back when you first start,
you have like, no problem working.
'Cause at the time, it's not
like, it's something new.
It's only later on when
you you've been doing it
for a while and you realize,
"Holy shit, this is unhealthy as fuck."
- At the beginning, you think,
"Whoa, I'm getting paid
to do something I like.
"This is changing the system."
- I'm just gonna keep going then.
- This is just a life hack,
I'm gonna do this forever.
- Well in psychology,
we do say that a job, is when you say,
"Oh, I only got paid that
much for doing all that."
A career is when you say,
"Wow, I got paid that
much for just doing that."
So, I don't know.
- I mean, it's pretty true.
(all laughing)
Big brain.
- So there was that, yeah.
And so since then, like YouTube
just had its ups and downs,
but I've loved it ever since.
I don't seem like-
- You've been doing it for what,
how many years now, five, six?
- Maybe like six, I think.
- When did you start, like 2014?
- I uploaded my first video, 2014,
and then I blew up in 2015, I think.
- I feel like since I met you,
your like perspective
on YouTube has changed.
- It has a lot.
- I feel like you were the one
who was like the most grindy
out of anyone I knew.
And then you like
flipped the opposite way.
Like I had never heard you
talk about it or when you do,
it's always like one big
thing that you're working on.
- I think it's because,
especially with personality,
like you just...
I don't know.
At some point you just
wanna get grounded again
and you just realize
YouTube, isn't everything.
It's still something I love to do.
And now, it is just my job.
And now, I don't really...
That fire of me wanting to like,
"I wanna grow as a
YouTuber," I'm already there.
So I'm just like,
now I just wanna go back to my roots.
And that's why I just talk
with my other personal friend.
- That just happened over time?
- Over time, yeah.
YouTube just does some weird stuff to you.
I think fame does that a lot as well.
And just like the pressure
of being a personality,
there's like now this
whole part of my life
that has nothing to do with what I do.
And I think you already know some stuff
that I do in private, like just for fun.
- Was there a point where
you've realized that
or was it something that's gradual,
that like build up with time?
- I think it was a gradual thing because-
- I feel like if you're-
Some people love being in the spotlight
and love having all the attention on them,
and then others I meet,
and they get crushed by it.
- Yeah, because I feel like,
some YouTubers who I've met,
who their YouTube is so intertwined
with not only their job,
but their self-worth as
well and I feel like-
- I know it's like, "If I'm
not successful on YouTube,
"then I'm not successful as a person."
- I'd say it was like the first time
I started to feel like I was
looking at it like a job,
was like really scary.
'Cause I was like, "Am I losing my touch?"
I'm like, "Am I going
to be a bad YouTube now,
'cause I'm not thinking
about it 24 seven?"
For the first few months
I was really struggling
to just understand that it's okay
to not think about this all the time.
And then now, I feel like I
have a pretty healthy balance
with it, where I honestly
don't really think
about it that much.
I kind of plan what I need to do.
- I think it also helps us all to like...
Especially you and I have
really like gone down
in terms of how sporadic we upload.
'Cause we used to upload way
more frequently than we did.
- We used to try and do two
a week, and that was like-
- I'd say daily.
- Daily is like, "I don't
know how you do that, but-"
- I went from daily to weekly.
- Fucking psychos right here.
(all laughing)
- You used to do a lot, right?
Four, three times a week, right?
- No, I didn't.
I used to upload just three
times week, that's it.
- Just three times.
- It really wasn't that bad,
I mean, Joey, at the time,
like you did upload daily.
I was like three times a week, and-
- But that's what
YouTube wanted back then.
Like three times a week ,I
don't think it would work now.
It would be unoptimized.
- Yeah, I think I'm at a
point now, like you know-
- Not me maxing.
I think I'm at a point now,
where I just upload like
once a week or whatever.
- I think the audience has changed.
I think audiences would
just rather get something.
Well, I think two weeks is kind of long,
but one week, shoot a
good video once a week
and it seems to do the job.
- [Agnes] Yeah, pretty much.
- Exactly because it's so saturated now
and there's so much choice.
- And it gives me a lot of time
to just live my life rather than...
'Cause YouTube is kind of weird.
I feel like people kind
of go on either side
of the spectrum.
It's either like the
business versus the artists,
if you are too far into the artists,
then you kind of lose focus
on how your business is doing.
And some people don't care
about that, which is fine.
But then you get people who
like care about the numbers
way too much.
And then it kind of
integrates into their life
and their self-worth
and even just the people
that they hang out with.
Like, "Unless they're a big YouTuber,
"I won't hang out with
them", kind of thing.
- Definitely.
- That's weird
- It's sad because I've seen both sides.
- I think it's just like that side.
Like I've seen that so
frequently, which is why I'm like,
"Okay, I don't wanna fall into that."
So, I decided to back up and
just make my own private life.
- It really infuriates
me when I've had people
who I thought were good friends
and then maybe I introduced
them to one of my friends
and they are not a YouTuber,
and they'll be like, "I
don't care who they are."
- Yeah, I think that's
the biggest tell for me.
Where, especially 'cause,
whenever we travel
or something like that,
we always try to bring
our friends with us,
if they're not YouTubers
or doing something else.
- Even if they are peasants,
bring them along, it's fine.
- Even if they are
normies, those commonies.
Imagine working in an office
job, ( laughs) I'm joking.
- No, like some times you do that.
- I used to work at the BBC.
- Yeah, I know.
(all laughing)
I didn't mention that you did.
- Like we always hear
it as kind of a joke,
but it's true, sometimes you...
I hate saying it like this,
but remember the little
people, but more like,
remember your roots, go
back to that, and like-
- I just think, because normally
YouTubers tend to hang out
with other YouTubers because
the lifestyle is similar.
- I mean like you're just
there and that's fine.
Like you can make YouTuber friends.
I just don't like it when
people like, it's obvious.
- Only have YouTuber friends.
Yeah and it's so obvious,
a lot of the times where
it's like, "Oh, hi."
Like, when they start sucking
another big YouTubers Dick so hard,
like to the point, it's just like...
Then the point, like, what is
the point of that friendship,
if all you ever want is...
Just like, your friendship
only exists on YouTube,
but if it doesn't exist
outside of YouTube,
then it's like-
- For me, the telltale sign
of that might be happening
with someone that I know,
is when the only times
they will ever DM me,
is for YouTube collab.
And that's where I'm just like,
"Ooh, okay you don't give
a shit about me at all."
- Yeah, I've had a few
messages where it's like,
it's really obvious that
the only time they message
is when they need something,
which is also why I very rarely
do collabs on my channel.
The people I've done
collabs on my channel,
is people like I genuinely
had like a connection with
because I'm very much a person
that will show their emotions on camera
because I'm not gonna fake anything.
So for example, just recently,
I just collaborated with Sharla and Emma,
but those are two people
that I've been friends with for years.
And just recently, have
I felt comfortable enough
to actually do a video with them.
So, that if anyone wanted to
know why I don't collaborate
with that many YouTubers, that's why,
and it's also the introvert in me.
Any introvert will understand
that, we keep the people,
we're very picky with people,
but the people that we do
pick, we keep very tightly.
- Yeah, you're very much like
the opposite to me on that.
I'm like, "Hell yeah, come on,
let's go, let's go hang out."
- Yeah, but like...
And that's fine.
Like for me, it's easier.
'Cause then I just know what people,
I already know, want to
hang out like at night.
But when there's too
many people, I feel like,
"Man, I gotta balance everyone out."
And then I don't.
Like it's too many people to deal with.
- It's hard to maintain.
- A little bit just for me.
- I just hope that the
people I make friends with,
that they don't expect me to like-
- The actual friends, they
don't expect anything out of it
other than your friendship.
- Yeah, they, understand
if we're both busy,
I don't know.
- It's not about like, I'm
friends with this person
to get something out of them.
- Yeah, exactly because for me,
I don't do collabs on my channel at all.
That's just because my content,
I felt it doesn't really
lend well to collabs,
especially since it's
very scripted content.
So, I just wanna hang out with people.
I don't care, I never
care about the collabs,
that's never in my mind,
I just like meeting new people.
- Well, that's the thing, it's like,
I probably only collabed
with like half the YouTubers
I actually have become friends with.
That's just purely because
some YouTubers I know,
where it's like,
it doesn't matter how much
I've been this concept
of anime content,
there's just no way I can
integrate their personality,
what they're about, into the content.
And you know, nothing
against the YouTubers I know,
it's just how the content is.
- I'm not even against collabs,
'cause watching you guys collab,
I'm just like, that seems kind of fun.
(all laughing)
- It is fun, its really fun.
And there is a part of me where it's like,
I really want to be able to make content
that I can literally get
any type of YouTuber onto,
but because I've fucked myself over
with what I've called myself,
so I can't really just do
like a outfit of the day shit
and bring you on like,
just a female YouTuber.
- 'Cause one of the biggest
things I worry about as well,
is just the chemistry.
'Cause sometimes I see people collab,
and like, "You know, that's-"
You can tell on camera,
that that's the first time
they've ever hung out.
Had like a IRL conversation.
- Yeah, I actually recently did a video
where I got my fortune
told in Japan and I even...
And there's like two
things that are happening.
So, I show like the
actual raw footage of me
talking to the fortune teller,
I had never met her before in my life.
So my introvertedness,
actually came out in that
where I only said like one word answers,
but to be fair, I was also listening,
'cause she had a lot to say,
it was a lot for me to process.
But then there's the part of
me that's like in my room,
where I was actually very outspoken.
And I think I even said
in that video, I'm like,
"Yeah, you're looking at
two different Aki's here."
That AKI right there is
actually the introverted one
and I'm just listening.
The one, you're seeing-
- That's the real one.
(both laughing)
- And then the one that
you're seeing right now,
is just my thoughts and I'm comfortable
to get them out right now.
- 'Cause I think when we hang out,
it's like very different
to when we hang out
and there's someone else
that you don't really know.
- Pretty much, and that's
with anyone that...
Like, when there's someone that's new.
Again, I've learned this in psychology,
but you tend to look at the person
that you're most comfortable with.
Even if you're talking to
someone else it's like,
"Yeah, you guys went to that park, right?
"Yeah, okay, yeah."
(laughs) Like, eye language
just says so much about it
and I'm definitely someone that-
- I love making eye contact right away,
I'm just like, "Hi, how are you doing?"
- With no other expression?
- I actually had to learn how
to make eye contact because-
- It's a skill, I think it's a skill.
- As a kid, I was like
a socially awkward kid.
I'd be talking to someone and be like,
"Hey, how's your day going?
"Yeah its good."
- I have no idea where
I learned social skills.
How do you learn that shit?
I swear, I was terrible.
- I don't know.
- I think it just like...
Especially when you become
an adult, you're forced to.
'Cause like if you're that one adult
where you just can't maintain eye contact-
- I swear I couldn't talk
to anyone when I was a kid.
Like I was terrible.
- I never learned, like
I've never talked to someone
and been like,
I have to keep looking into their eyes.
- I have.
- Really?
- Actually, there's been one anime
that's been airing the
season and it's like-
- Anime talk (laughs).
- We just need to remind you guys
that this is an anime podcast.
- No, this is real 'cause
it's like relevant to me.
And that's why I'm watching it.
And it's like, I think it's like Jacku
or something like that, is
a bottom tier character.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's about this like pro gamer
who has like zero social skills
and he meets this hot anime girl,
it's like a Howard rom-com.
But the premise, is that she
teaches him social skills.
Like they're a game.
So like, she gave him a five.
She gave him a place,
- Look at the eyes(indistinct).
No, exactly, she was just like,
"Okay, so this person brought up X topic.
"And that like really define
the flow of this conversation."
And it really like broke
down like social skills
and social circles and like gamified them.
And that was like really interesting to me
'cause that's basically what
I had to do in university.
'Cause I was just like,
"This is not natural to me.
"I've got to fucking engineer this shit."
And then it became second
nature along the way.
But like I needed those training wheels
when I was learning it
because I was like that
socially awkward as a kid.
- But that's like a cool way to learn it.
Because it's a concept that
you can kind of understand.
- I think there's a healthy
way and an unhealthy way
to go about it.
'Cause some people just like take this
and game-ify it too much
that they just kind of become a robot.
And I feel like it's healthy.
It's like, look at this person,
and then look at this person.
And then look at this person again.
- It's just helpful.
It's just helpful, it's kind
of like training wheels.
- Eye contact is hard, like
too little and you're like,
talk to me.
And too much, it's like, whoa, whoa.
- I've meet those people where
it's like hard eye contact.
They don't even blink.
That's like, I'm talking to an Android.
- Just occasionally look
right, look away, look back.
And that's kind of what's happening.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Who teaches this shit?
How do I learn this shit?
- No, no one does.
No one does teach it.
- You know it's one thing
that drives me insane
that some people do,
and some people don't do,
okay, let's say we're all here,
and then, let's say Aki
brings a friend to the group.
It drives me insane,
when the person who brought the friend in,
doesn't introduce them to everyone.
I'm like, "I'm waiting,
who is this person?"
Is that's awkward?
I feel feel awkward for them.
Please tell me who they are.
- I've had times where,
because that person didn't do it,
I've had to awkwardly
go up to and be like,
"Oh, I'm Joey, by the way."
- I don't have to be,
"Who are you by the way?"
It should be like, "Aki,
Connor, Connor, Aki."
Right away, do it right away.
- Do you know one of the biggest things
that I've found is important,
even though I never thought about it,
as a kid, the handshake.
(all laughing)
Now that we've gone through
like met so many people,
you can judge so much about a
person by just the handshake.
- The confidence in which
they whip out their hand.
- Yeah exactly, it's an entire process
and it's like an entire science behind it.
And then sometimes someone whips out
like the weakest handshake
and you're just not looking
forward to this handshake.
- It is like the slimiest
coldest, like wet hand.
- Or like, when they just do this,
and they're just waiting for you.
- Sometimes you just
feel like you're grabbing
a dead piece of meat,
and you're just like,
"Hello, how are you?"
- I love it, when the strength comes out,
they turn their body slightly.
They are like, "Hello."
- The shoulder needs come out.
- That's how, you know that
they are keen for the hand.
- Honestly if you want to
make a good impression,
handshakes are so fucking OP.
They are, they really are.
- The strongest ones that
I've learned is like,
the shoulder upfront, but also going in
while maintaining eye contact like that.
Don't even look at the hand.
- That's what my dad did to you,
the first time he met you.
- Yeah, that was scary.
- That was more of like saying a message
when he did it like this, like just shake.
If I was like my dad and you were Joey,
he was like, "Hi, how are you doing?"
- He like whipped the handout,
and I was like, "Oh fuck,
I gotta catch this."
- Yeah, and then after that
I remember like my dad,
he boxes and we have also
like a sandbag in our garage.
And then like, Joey is just like,
"You wanna see my new sand bag?"
And he fucking punches the shit out of it.
He's like, "Oh, it's pretty good, huh."
- But I was like, "Maintain eye contact,
"maintain eye contact."
(all laughing)
- But yeah, my life's
kind of weird, I'm sorry.
- No, that's fine.
- I remember, I'll never...
Can I tell a story
of when I had dinner with
your family without you?
- Was that in London?
- Yes (laughs).
- Oh my Lord, oh God okay.
- Can you imagine how (indistinct)
(all laughing)
- I had dinner with Aki
and her whole family
without Aki there.
- Wait, can you please give them context?
- I will, okay.
- I wasn't invited to
my own family dinner.
- So, Aki's family was
staying in a hotel in London,
but I think it was quite...
I mean, hotels in London
are very expensive.
- Yeah, but I wanted to
give it as a gift to them.
- So they were staying in a nice, in bank.
Quite nice area of London, quite posh.
- Meanwhile, these two were
just staying at my house.
- At a guy's place.
- In my room.
- Not even in the same city,
quite far away.
It's like that the Apple was Gatwick.
So it's like 30 minutes
up, 30 minutes down.
- Yeah, so I had Connor kind
of helping my family there.
- I felt so bad, 'cause it
was in the middle of July
or August, July.
- It was during the heat wave.
- And I took them on the
underground, on the central line,
which is basically like the domino table.
I took them on the worst busiest train,
with all that luggage.
It was so hot, and I was
like, "I'm so sorry."
I could tell Aki's dad was
like having a mental breakdown
'cause it was so hot.
He had so much luggage-
- And there's no AC in the (indistinct).
- My dad also has, a
really bad back as well.
- And I was trying to help
carry as much luggage as I can.
Like, "You good, you good?
"You wanna hydrate?"
- (laughs) You wanna hydrate?
- So I took them all
the way to their hotel
and I think it was thanks.
They were like, let's invite
Connor out for dinner.
So, I just had dinner with Aki's family.
- Mean while Aki and I
chilling in Brian (indistinct).
(all laughing)
- Joey was like on my
hammock or something.
(all laughing)
- It was so bizarre.
- Yeah, I know.
I can't imagine.
- Yeah, I remember Connor texting me.
He's like, "I'm so sorry."
My mom's watching this too.
- Hello.
Your food is lovely that
you prepared for me.
- I remember he was
texting me, being like,
"Dude, I feel so fucking bad."
- But your mom's always so nice to me.
So she knows wants me
to feel really welcomed,
so I was like-
- Your mum's nice to everybody I feel.
- Yeah she is.
- It's very hard to piss your mom off.
- Your parents are always
super open and super nice.
- Yeah, I like the way they-
- I like.
(all laughing)
- I don't know what to say?
- I like my parents the way they are.
Your parents are just like,
if you're a friend of Aki,
you're part of the family.
- Yeah, yeah, pretty much.
- Yeah and even more kudos
if you're a YouTube streamer.
'Cause like at the moment
they find that out,
they'll keep like, do
you guys watch Harry?
- They'll be like, "Give
me your anolis right now."
Like, did you guys watch Harry Potter?
Like, do you guys watch Harry Potter?
You know, Ron's dad like
being really obsessed
with like muggles?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's my parents like
with YouTubers and streamers.
- So its a different bread of humans.
- I remember that my mom,
she texted me being like,
"Oh my God, Bill Delfina's back."
And I was like, "What?"
(all laughing)
- I watched their sex tape.
- Yeah, she was like,
"How do you think her
only friends is going?"
I was like, "I don't
care, I don't care dude."
So my parents are very like on point.
- I feel that whole like
welcoming side of your parents,
especially though like,
I feel ties in with like the
Philipino like mentality.
- So my family, funny enough,
we actually are all introverts,
but when you meet them,
you wouldn't think so.
It's mainly because if
you're a friend of mine,
then they'll more than be
happy that to open up to you.
- Yeah but I feel-
- Your mom kept giving
me food, I was like-
- That's just a Philipino thing.
- That's South East Asian.
- I was in AX and her
mum was checking up on me
more than my mum was.
(all laughing)
I was like what's going on here.
- I don't know what it is
about Southeast Asian parents,
they're just families
where they try to solve
every fucking life
problem by offering food.
- Aki's mom has bought me
more underwear and socks
than my own parents
have, that's says a lot.
- Yeah, my mom well,
she always like delivers
just some stuff from overseas.
And she always gets like
six bags of like Cheetos.
- Like every time when I was
a kid, I'd visit my family.
I'd either be like,
"Oh, you don't seem
like you're eating well,
"here have more food.
"Oh, are you feeling well?
"Here, have more food."
"Oh, you're not feeling well?
"It's 'cause you haven't
eaten, have more food."
- And if you're fat, then
they'll just be like,
"Oh, you're getting so fat, eat."
(all laughing)
Which is weird, you know, like...
I don't know if it's
like in any other family.
I just noticed with a
lot of Asian families,
being called fat is a good thing
because it means that you're being-
- You're being fed well.
- I feel that's a specifically
Southeast Asian thing.
- It's like, "Oh, you're so fat now.
"Oh my God, do you have a boyfriend?"
Like it's, yeah, so its always-
- Because that's just
how it works in Japan.
Like even if you lose weight
or like gain muscle, you're
like, "Damn, he got fat."
I was like, "I just gained
muscle but all right, thanks."
Thanks for destroying my self esteem.
- That's definitely, one
thing about Asian culture,
that's like very different from the West,
where people aren't afraid to comment
on other people's weights.
- Yeah, right?
- Yeah, where it's a very
sensitive topic in like,
if you comment on someone
else's weight in England
or the US especially,
but here in Asia, it's a free for all.
- It's like, we're just
saying what we're seeing.
- You just meet like the
amount of family reunions
or family gatherings I've gotten to,
I've been to sorry.
And people, the first
thing they say is like,
"Damn you're getting
a bit fat aren't you?"
And I'm like, "I'm fucking thin as fuck,
"what are you talking about?"
- [Aki] I remember-
- And you're the only thinnest guy.
- I remember when we were
staying at a gardens place
and then like, I don't eat spicy food,
which I know is like really
blaspheming in Southeast Asia.
- It is.
- Yeah, I know, sorry,
but I remember like your
mom was gonna make us food.
And then she asked like,
"Is there anything that AKI can't eat?"
And you said, "Oh, she
can't eat spicy food."
And then she's like,
"Well, I'm making curry.
"What do I do?"
(all laughing)
So she tried to work around it
and it was like those amazing
fucking spicy noodles.
I don't know what the name of it is.
- Like, Garnt's mom dead ass
came up to me and was like,
"I have never made a Thai
curry without chilly.
"I don't even know if it's
gonna taste good at all.
"I've never done this before."
- Yeah, it was still really good.
I had never had like those, like...
What is it like, those noodles?
- It's like a Southeast Asian-
- What is it called?
- It's like a rice noodle.
- Yeah, it's like a rice noodle.
I can't remember the name right now.
- It's fucking good.
- Topical people are fuming
right now, what is it?
- It's not (speaking in foreign language).
Oh, what's even the English name of that?
- I don't know.
- Rice noodles.
- It's like these, yeah.
It's just like these piles of like noodles
and then you just take them
and dip them in the Curry, I think.
- It's on the screen, Moodan
you can figure it out.
- I don't know, what it is, but
- Every Southeast Asian, is
just like (gasping heavily).
- Fuck, am failing my own language.
- I don't know, at what age I realized
there was more than one type of noodle.
(Joey laughing)
- Wow.
- Yeah, how did you like,
as a white man, as the token white man-
- I feel like your view of noodles
was like my view of bread.
Cause like, for me, every
bread was just the same.
I'm sure I'm saying this
and everyone in Europe
just like dies a little.
- No what, bread is so varied.
There's definitely way more types of bread
than are noodles though.
- No.
- No, I don't think so.
- Yeah, there is.
I know there is, come on.
- We're gonna have to...
Ashley, can you look up to see
if there are more types of bread
than there are types of noodles?
- A hundred percent.
- I think there are more types of noodles.
- No there is not.
- We'll figure that out.
- No pastas, no.
- No pastas, pastas no.
(all laughing)
Yes, I'll have a noodle bolognese please.
- Oh my gosh.
- Well at least you don't try
to eat it with chop sticks.
- We're gonna start world war three
or that won't come up.
- We should stop talking about food.
We should stop talking about food.
So you mentioned your
real name at the beginning
of this episode, right?
- I did, my name is Agnes.
- Is there anything-
- Why would you say it like that?
- My name is Agnes.
- You're saying it like an
Android, my name is Agnes.
- It's for the record, not
even my family calls me that.
So that's why I also didn't
come out with it 'cause it was-
- It was freak ass.
- Yeah.
- But like, is there like anything else?
I mean, I guess we're just gonna dedicate
this Trash Taste to like news
things that Aki's never said.
- 107 things you didn't
know about Aki Dearest.
- Oh God, okay.
I don't even know where to start.
I mean, like I was mentioning earlier,
I could probably talk about the fact
that I was in military school for like,
or for military class for like four years.
- What is that?
- Yeah what is that?
- So its called N-J-R-O-T-C,
Navy Junior Reserve Officer
Training Corps, and it's like-
- Damn, that was drilled in to you man.
How many times did you
have to repeat that?
- What's the purpose of this?
- Its when you wanna go into the military.
And so when you-
- You want to go into the military?
- Yes.
- Oh, okay.
- To fight for their country, but yeah.
- I noticed that's a very American thing,
'cause it's like, I feel like in England-
- Its very patriotic.
- It's very patriotic, cause in England,
nobody talks about wanting
to go to the military,
I feel like people just
find themselves in there.
- You rarely hear about
kids who are like 15, 16,
who wanna go in the army
and last that parents in it.
- Yeah, so, I remember
when I came out on Twitter,
I was just like, "Oh, you know."
'Cause my mom had showed
me this old photo album.
And there was one of me in high
school, in my dress, blues,
sorry, that's the term for the uniform.
And I was like, "Oh shit, you know what?"
I never actually came out about that.
And that was like a huge part of my life.
- What age do you start that?
- When the moment you hit
high school, you can do it.
- So what do you have to do?
- And do you decide to do that
Or do your parents decide?
- I did.
- Because from age like 14,
you like decided I
wanna join the military?
- So I did not join-
- That is so American.
No, no, no, so my reason for joining
wasn't exactly for like
the most patriotic reason,
it was because how to
crush back in high school,
he was part of it.
And then he was like,
"Oh yeah, it's pretty cool in here."
And then I joined and it didn't work out,
but I stayed because I
actually started to like it.
- I actually joined the
military to impress a boy.
- Yeah, I know right.
It was weird, I had, so
when I came out about it
on Twitter, I had like this
huge imposter syndrome,
no one expected that of me, but-
- You're not like, so
you can join this thing,
but you're not like you don't
have to join the military.
- No, so the one that
I took in high school,
which by the way,
mine was actually the strictest
in the entire country.
This isn't just me saying
it, you can look it up,
but like when you can
join military if you want
and you get credited
more like when you join
ROTC in university or go
to military academies.
- So like an extra curricular?
- But yeah, basically, but
you get credited really well.
Especially at the one that I went to-
- So how many hours a
week would you do for?
- Well, the average high school
student has eight classes.
ROTC is part of that
schedule plus another one.
So I had nine classes.
- So what do you have to
do in military school?
- Oh God, so a lot of people
have misconceptions that like,
you have to learn how to fight
and use a gun or whatever,
but that's not for high schoolers.
- Was it like super strict?
You have to wake up at a certain time.
- It's a very disciplining
thing, it's not for everyone.
A lot of people get out
in their first year.
I stayed for all four, but basically like,
so you have like, once or twice a week,
you have to wear your uniform.
And yet it has to be completely perfect.
They look at every crease and fold
that you had to iron it well.
Like every time I put my hair up in a bun,
they had to check for a little flyaway.
So that should have to be like
gorilla glued down, you know?
Which I didn't do.
- Put some gorilla glue-
- Which I didn't do.
- You saying this, makes so much sense
because we obviously hang out,
like outside of this and flex.
- I think this has caused me to have
the biggest resting bitch face ever.
- There, will be certain moments,
where you go into what
I call, Aki mum mode,
where you know, everyone
else is a fucking monkey.
And then you're just like
there and you're just there
to sort shits out.
It's when something goes
wrong, and you're just like,
"Okay, mum mode, activate."
And you're like, "What are you doing?
"What are you doing?
"I'ma sort this out, I'ma sort that out."
Hearing, this makes so much sense now.
- She walks into a room and it's like,
"There's not enough
discipline in this room."
Trying to slap it in.
- But the program I was into,
it's an extremely disciplining course.
And you get credited a lot back
if you go in to university.
- So what's like a typical day?
So in the school, you have
to go through inspection.
So you all march outside and
then you stand at attention
and you have to learn the art
of not showing any expression.
And then you have to sound off.
Like, someone comes in front of you,
the drill inspector or instructor,
and then he asks you a question
and then you have to yell it
in his or her face and say, "Sir, ma'am,"
and answer the question that he had.
If you stutter, then you
get chewed out a lot.
Like, it's a very
disciplining thing there.
So for example, in front of me,
you would shit your pants every time,
when it was inspection
first thing in the morning.
So if I had a girl in front
of me, I'd be so nervous.
I'd say like, "Good morning, sir."
And then she'd chew me out a lot.
- Chewing out, as in like
screaming at your face.
- Chewing out, is the term that we use
when you're getting yelled at a lot.
So, oh and then along with...
I don't know if any other
ROTC course ever did this
in high school as well, but I
did train also for four days
every year at USMC,
United States, Marine Corps in San Diego.
And that's with real drill
instructors where you have to go
into the barracks, you get pushed.
- This is so bizarre.
- I know, I'm telling you, I had a huge,
big imposter syndrome and I
can't believe I never came out
about this on the internet.
- Because it just completely
goes against your personality.
- I know, it's like I tell you,
it's a whole different part of my life
has nothing to do with this.
- All I think of, when it
comes to like military classes,
like, you know, that scene
in "Full Metal Jacket."
Where the dude is just like
fucking yelling at them.
- I honestly thought to make a video of me
reacting to military movies
and like ROTC movies,
just to see if they're
accurate enough, but like yeah.
- Ex military professional.
- Okay, so I'll just tell
you this, that being at USMC,
you're never gonna get
like more verbally abused
than like having four marine instructors.
- I can imagine.
- When did you decide you
weren't gonna join the military
because if you completed all four years,
I guess, what percentage of the class
that completed four years
went on to join the military?
- Wait, like, everyone that
enlisted, like how many guys-
- How many ended up going to the military?
- I'd say like, at least like maybe half.
Yeah, it was 50, 50.
Because the thing is, when
you're in this program-
- Probably university,
it's like four years,
you figure out you don't like it.
- Well no, because
people join this program,
not just to join the military.
It's because it looks
very good on your resume.
So like, you can literally
do a lot of things
just by saying that you even
did this in the first place,
'cause it's literally not for everyone.
- It's like doing like Duke of Edinburgh.
It just looks good on your resume.
- That's what they say.
- That's what they said.
- When you first...
When I first joined
every friend that I made,
I'd say, I only had one
friend left by the end of it.
Like, and you know.
- Did you enjoy it?
- You know what?
You feel actually a
sense of accomplishment
when you do it, especially-
- That doesn't sound like you enjoyed it.
(all laughing)
- I don't feel a sense of
partially things I enjoyed.
When you're in it, like
every day of your life,
you're like shitting your pants.
Like not wanting to get yelled at.
And it's like,
I really hope I don't fuck up,
like shining shoes and all that.
Like, and just the
physical and mental, like-
- I just don't get how
people would wanna do this.
- It's because, it makes you feel-
because you toughen up
and I feel like people
are a lot stronger than they think.
- There's other ways to toughen up.
- It's a learning experience.
- Yeah, it's a learning experience.
And I feel like in any other situation,
people would call what
I went through, abuse.
But like, you go in like
with the possibility
of going to the military
and you have to be strong.
So in order to do that,
you're pushed to your limits.
- I've met some people who joined
because they felt like they needed
someone to like guide them,
like tell them what to do
and get their shit together.
- Pretty much, and it's not for someone
who doesn't like being told
what to do, I can tell you that.
- Yeah, obviously.
- Yeah and the actual Marine Corps base,
I remember like, you'd wait,
you'd be yelled at for
pretty much the entire day.
Then you'd go to bed at
midnight and you get to sleep
for four hours.
And that's the only time of
peace that you have to yourself
and that four in the morning,
the drill instructors,
like come banging on the door
and then like rip your sheets off.
And then they tell you to get up
and you have to stand at attention,
but you're like all dizzy and stuff.
And then by the time I ranked
up to chief petty officer,
which I guess it's just high ranking.
I got to be one of the people
to chew out other cadets.
- That would have been fun.
- You know what?
All of that.
- How did that feel?
- So satisfying.
(all laughing)
So, I went through like three
and a half years by this point
and being yelled at.
And then now you get to be the person,
to yell at other people.
- Its making a bunch of psychopaths.
- So basically like, we'd
have our platoon leader,
we'd be lined up in front of the door
of our assigned cadets.
And then she'd like,
whisper and count to three.
And then on three,
you all have to like smash
the door and get open.
And then just go ahead.
- You basically like fucking
Kool-Aid man, actually.
- Essentially, yeah, that's
essentially what I did.
And I made a few people
cry at that, so I'd like-
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I fucked them up.
- Is there like a badge
of honor that wear there?
Because like, it's so unexpected
when you first meet me.
- Achievement unlocked, cause trauma.
- We've got three cries in
here, let's see if we gonna cry.
- I don't wanna see your
medals or achievement.
How many have you made cry,
how many kids you made cry?
- So, no, I don't know.
It was a learning experience.
And again, it's not for
everyone, but once you're done,
you're at least proud that you did it.
- You know what the equivalent is?
That's the equivalent of like,
being the youngest in high school
and you having to wait for the seniors
to go on the bus first.
And then when you become
the senior, you're like,
"Get out of the way kids,
"I waited five years for this shit."
- That's exactly what that is.
- All I'm thinking,
is you must have really
fucking liked this boy,
what the fuck?
(all laughing)
- I mean, I was a freshman
and I was like 14 or 15 so.
- But still, even if there
was like the girl of my dreams
and she's like, female guard of the army,
you wanna come?
I'll be like, "I'm good, I'm good."
- I wasn't really like told properly
like how strict ROTC was.
And I didn't realize that
we were the strictest
in the entire country.
But then like-
- But you wanna figure that out.
Like first couple of times.
- But then I stayed.
- I'm the kind of person who's like,
"I'ma do it and ask questions after."
- I am, and when I was experiencing it,
I stayed because I was
like, "I don't know.
"I actually really like this."
- What did you like about it?
- I don't know, because
it's really pushing you
to your limits.
To rank up, you have to
do well in academics,
and you have to do well in physicals,
and you have to completely
pass it with flying colors,
if you wanna get to the rank that I did,
which took four years.
- So you say you got into
this because you liked a boy.
Was there like a point or moment
when in your first year-
- This boy isn't worth it?
- In your first year, when you
just had this realization of,
"Oh, shit this is what I've
gotten myself into, fuck me."
- Oh yeah, no, that was,
like in the first day.
(all laughing)
- I feel like-
- And yet you're like four years easy.
- I feel like without people like you,
we wouldn't have raves because you know,
you're the kind of person who
would turn up to something
like, "Well, I guess I got to do it now."
No one likes the brave when
they turn up and I just leave.
- You know what's funny when I was 18-
- I'm committed, I'm here now.
- What's funny, when I was
18, I actually held a rave.
That was during very different Aki time.
- Where?
- My house.
- What?
- You held a rave in your house.
- My parents would execute me on the spot
if they found that out.
- Sounds like an American pie plot there.
- That was a very crazy party.
But yeah, I think nowadays
I have my fault, like other,
like fellow cadets, I went with like,
they send me DMS and they
still call me by my last name.
We never call each other
by our first names.
And they're just like, "Holy shit'.
Like you're on YouTube
and meanwhile, like-
- (indistinct) Without my bill provider.
- Yeah, have any of your friends?
- That's my tax.
Have, you guys ever seen
messages from people
that you didn't even talk to?
That recognized what you do now?
- Yeah, oh yeah, all the time.
- I actually, got one
message of this person
who I hadn't talked to since school
and she she's a teacher now.
So last time I met her,
was like years and years and years ago.
And she messages me out
of the blue to be like,
"Yo, I haven't talked to you in years,
but can you do me a small favor?
And she-
- That's a never a good sign.
And she asked me to
record a message for her,
for her students.
'Cause apparently her students
were like big fans of me.
And, I was just like, "You
know what, fuck it I'll do it."
You know, "You can be the
cool teacher for your kids,
"I'm gonna let you on it.
"Yeah, I'm gonna let you have this."
And so I record the message.
And apparently after that,
yeah, she was the cool fucking teacher.
- It's so bizarre because
like ever since during uni,
when I was doing it,
like I never told my uni
friends or high school friends
that I was a YouTuber.
So, like when I got all
these messages on Facebook
from like high school
friends that I haven't seen,
in like fucking 10 years almost,
them being like, "Yo, I saw
you on YouTube the other day,
"I've be watching you for a while.
I'm like-
- What'd you say to that?
How do you react to this?
- I was like, "Thanks", but
also, hey, it's been 10 years.
Like, "What are you doing?"
You know it's like, yeah.
Like how do you react to that?
- Would you guys go to
your high school reunion?
- I don't know.
- My high school was tiny,
so I felt like I was pretty good friends
with most of them.
- I think I had like, like
30, 40 people in my year.
Yeah, it was really, really small.
- I had like 800.
- Jesus Christ, you had
more people in your class
than we did our entire school.
- My school was attached
to another school,
which was an English speaking school.
And I think one of their years
was nearly the same size
as our whole school.
- Our entire school, I
think had like 600 kids.
- Yeah, something around that.
- And we were considered one
of the biggest schools too.
- Oh wow, Australia really be-
- Australia really be all
over the place with that shit.
- I don't know, 'cause do reunions happen
every 10 years, is it?
- I think it's meant to be 10 years.
- 'Cause who arranges these?
- I recently looked to see
if my school was doing one.
And usually it's on-
- Where are you looking?
- Your school's website.
And there is a specific
section for alumni.
- Your school has a website?
- Yeah
- Yeah, our school had a website.
- Oh, really?
My, school has like a
section that does alumni.
- I've always wondered
who or is it like someone
from the year?
Or is it like one of the teachers or?
- It's the school.
It's the school.
- My high school-
- I think it's the students sometimes.
- My high school union,
which I couldn't go to
because I was busy at AX.
(all laughing)
- I was busy partying in LA.
- I was just in LA.
- I was busy in lA, I'd say, yeah,
but it was sorted out by one
of the people in my class.
So, it wasn't even the school
that sorted my one ass.
'Cause for me it would be next year 2022,
would be 10 years.
- I imagine that's when high
school reunions were a thing,
it served a pretty good
purpose, which was,
you could actually see these people
who you hadn't seen in 10 years.
But now, it's like, well,
I've got a friend on Facebook
and you see their Instagram photos.
- Even if you have some on Facebook-
- I feel like the purpose of
it has really like diminished.
It's still good.
I think I would still go
because I'd like to see
everyone I talk to everyone about.
- I actually I really wanted
to go, but I wasn't like-
- I like to go if there was
like, the teachers there as well
that you were like...
Catch up with teachers that
you were really friendly with.
- Surely it's gotta be like...
Depending on how you
wanna go, is depending on,
is your life better than when
you're in high school, right?
'Cause some people it's up or down.
It should be up.
Some people maybe went down a little bit,
maybe their golden era was school.
Then it's like, "Do I wanna go?"
- That's true, well, yours
was last year, right?
Or this year, I guess.
- What the high school reunion?
- Yeah, 10 years.
'Cause when did you graduate?
- 2011.
- Yeah, so it'd be this year.
- Yeah, it'd be this year.
And that's why I was checking.
'Cause I was like, Oh,
it's reaching 10 years.
And they're like for us,
we have our school's website
and there's literally a section
for alumni and it says like
homecoming and you get to log in
and say, "Are you going?"
And I saw a list of everyone who's going.
And it's so organized.
Like it's because our school
has actually been around
for a while, so they've
had the time, I guess.
- Our school barely has a Twitter I think.
I don't even know what that-
- I don't know if my
school has a Twitter go on.
- And like I just-
- That'd be weird.
- Yeah.
- I'd follow my school on Twitter.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I think I just wanted
to check who is going,
but in order to do that, I
had to sign up to the website.
But I think it put me on the list.
So then, I got these messages
from like old high
school people like being,
"You're going?"
And I'm like, Oh yeah.
- No, no, I'm just stalking you.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm just seeing.
- I just wanna know what you're all up to.
- I'm just looking, promises, no promises,
I'm gonna show up.
- 'Cause I've heard like
there are some high schools
where like say it, like
they don't have a website,
where it's literally just someone
from that year being like,
'I've like booked the pub down the road."
- That's exactly what
happened in my school.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It was literally just a Facebook group
that everyone got invited to.
And apparently some people showed up
and I kind of wish I did.
- I remember when I was in high school,
I used to see them on TV all the time,
high school reunions.
"I'm like, I don't fucking see anyone.
"I don't want to meet anyone."
I'm just like that one
edgy anime characters.
Like they don't know-
- They all bullied me back then.
- They don't know that
I'm 1200 rating in chess.
I'm kidding but-
- It's that fucking meme,
where the guy standing
in the corner being like,
"They don't know I'm a pray con player."
(all laughing)
- For the first three years I was like,
" Fuck high school reunions,
I'm too cool for that."
But then more and more, it goes down.
I'm like, "You know what?
"I think I'd actually like
to see how everyone's doing.
- [Joey] Yeah, it'd be nice.
- I'm genuinely curious,
especially during quarantine,
I had this weekend when I'm just like,
"Man, I wonder what everyone's up to.
'Cause I feel like you get
that day one, like one day.
- Hire a PI, what would you do?
- Just like you see what
people were up to on Facebook
'cause you haven't
talked to them in years.
They had all these dreams and aspirations.
You do see some people
who are able to like...
Some people who have just
been stuck in their hometown.
- I feel like most people
wanted that, where I grew up.
I think it was almost expected
that you never really leave the town.
- I feel like that's
like a small town mindset
because I feel like a lot of people,
I talked to Sidney's family a lot
and the people living in her town
and everyone kind of just
stays in that one town.
And you're kind of like part of a clan.
And if you leave the clan,
you're like you're banished.
- You're dishonoring the clan.
- You're like the one who thought
you were too good for the lifestyle.
'Cause nearly like, I think
most people in my family,
like the old generations
live near the same area,
like within an hour drive.
And that's really weird to think about,
now that everyone lives
within like an hour drive,
like generations of families.
So I'm like, "Wait, did
no one have the idea
"to just like to leave?"
- I feel like as a kid,
it's a really like exotic
idea to live somewhere else
and be somewhere new.
But then I feel like you underestimate
just how much you like comfort.
Like, it really takes a lot
for someone to be like,
"I'm going to live in a new country."
And even for those of us who
live in different countries,
I know there are a lot
of things about home
that I'm sure you miss.
And even if you really like
the place that you live in,
there's a lot of things you miss as well.
- Like it's, massive props to like,
I think all three of our parents, right?
At least that had the balls to be like,
I'm just gonna go to this country
I know fucking nothing about.
- Yeah, so my parents took
it pretty like easily for me.
- Yeah, because it's
like Thailand to the UK,
Philippines to America, and in my case,
Japan to Australia, right?
It's like I've always wanted...
- For me I had like five generations,
that lived in the same town.
- Yeah my DNA test is like
a hundred percent British.
Like there's no one in my family
who's from any other
country in any like way.
- Well, because like you also,
not only will your parents not only moved
from the Philippines to America,
but they also moved to
probably the most like
non-friendly place for like
non-white people, right?
- So, I was technically born
in Bakersfield, California
'cause the labor clock was ticking.
But then as soon as I was born,
they went to Virginia and
then I lived half my life
in a place that honestly
sounds like the beginning
of an RPG game, it's
called Mechanicsville.
(all laughing)
It sounds like something
in Ni no Kuni, honestly.
- Yeah, it's like JLPG name.
- And then I-
- Starting village.
- Mechanicsville.
- what was weird is like,
I didn't even realize,
I had like this weird,
I guess almost country twain to my accent
until I came to the
West coast to Las Vegas.
And then people were teasing
of like the way I say, y'all
or the fact that I even say y'all a lot.
So I had to kind of like-
- I didn't realize that
Virginia, they say, y'all.
- Because it doesn't...
Because you look at it on a map
and it's like, "Oh, that's
in a Winnie, Texas."
- Of course, they're not-
- Texas is not the only in Las Vegas.
- No but just like someone who
knows nothing about America.
Like when you hear, y'all,
you immediately think,
"Oh yeah, Texas."
- You think southerner,
like that's what I think.
- Well, like Virginia is
not even in the South.
It's like kind of halfway
up on the East coast.
- But it is also kind of
like the founding ground.
- Yeah, but most people don't know that.
- No one knows that except me.
- I know that, I like U.S. history.
- Oh, really?
I like-
- Because there's barely any of it.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
Well compared to the UK.
- It's true there's nothing.
UK history is so fucking confusing.
- I went through a weird period
where I was obsessed with you
guys' history and culture.
- There so much of it.
- And there's like so
many bands that like,
I love that none of my friends
in the U.S. can relate to,
like, I think when we were at karaoke,
Garnt was so surprised I
was playing Kaiser Chiefs,
"I Predict a Riot," 'cause
it doesn't seem like,
or "Take That Shine."
- Take that, just to give you like my mom
and her friends love "Take That Shine."
That's the kind of demos
that they have in the UK.
- The first time she
was playing "Take That",
And I saw the music video I was like,
"Wow, the Backstreet
Boys gone really old."
- Especially at the UK Backstreet
Boys for middle-aged women
who are married, kind of
like that target then-
- (laughs) Yeah, but like,
that's the thing, right?
It's not until you look deep
into the whole U.S geography
that you realize that,
"Oh, just because it's
not in a particular area,
"it doesn't necessarily mean
they don't talk the same way."
Like I thought...
I don't know what I thought
people in Virginia sounded like,
I thought maybe they sounded
close to people from New York.
Yeah, I don't know.
- New York sounds like it's own thing.
- I feel like the way,
like some Americans are
probably hearing this right now
and being like, and
cringing because I feel like
the way we talk about American geography,
is how we feel when we hear Americans
talk about Europe or something.
- I think like someone from the UK,
I think that British accents
and like where that laid out,
is 20 times more confusing.
- Oh, 100%.
- I think they are as well.
- U.S. is so easy to keep
track of where someone's from,
based on the accent.
In the UK it's like,
"Oh, this guy sounds
completely different to person,
like A person sounds
different from B person.
They could either be like two hours apart
or literally five minutes
in a different town.
- 'Cause, what's confusing
about UK accents,
is that you can travel
a small enough distance
and have a widely varied accent.
- Well, I mean, just in London,
there's like 20 different accents.
And that's just a city,
whereas in Australia,
I think Australia is the
only English-speaking country
that doesn't have regional
dialects or accents.
- They just have like
degrees of like strength-
- Yeah but that's not based on you are,
that's based on how far
off the coast you are.
It's like the further inland you are,
the less you're able to understand them.
- Its just an Aussie scale basically.
And you, scale up.
- You scale up the further inland you go.
(all laughing)
It's like, "Oh yeah, you're
definitely from the inland.
"If I can't understand what
the fuck you're saying,
because like, you know,
like Kevin for example,
he's from Perth, which is
all the way on the West coast
and I'm from the East coast.
But if you ask someone who
doesn't know Australian accent-
- Yeah, you do sound the same.
- We would sound
exactly the same.
- You two sound exactly the same, yeah.
- That doesn't work in America at all.
Like in America,
you can clearly tell
if someone's from New
York versus California.
- You can pinpoint pretty
well, like even like Louisiana
or like just from Texas to California,
they just say like a lot.
Yeah, and I don't know, and-
- I wonder did your obsession with the UK
start with the crown?
Is that why?
- No, actually way before that.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Sorry to interrupt you.
- No, no, it's cool.
- Harry Potter?
- No, actually, no.
- What's your UK obsession?
You can normally pinpoint which
show gets people into like-.
- "The Beatles."
- What was the start for your TUB face.
(indistinct chatter)
- What is she saying?
- Black battler?
- Did it start with black battler?
- No, no, no, I don't know,
like is The Click Five British?
What the fuck is The Click Five?
- Come on, oh man, I feel like-
- What's is it, is it a TV show?
- Yeah, a band.
- After you watched "The
Crown", you were like-
May, can you look up The Click Five?
Yeah, after you watched "The
Crown", you were like, "Connor,
"I'm gonna learn Welsh."
- Are they British?
What?
- Yeah, Aki.
- Did she say that?
- Yeah.
- Nevermind.
- They're from Massachusetts.
I don't know who the hell it was.
I know, I just listened to a band
and then it just got
me into British music.
And then from there I just
got into British culture.
I just happened to also
be watching Harry Potter
at the time.
I guess I might have somewhere in there.
- Yeah, but then you watched "The Crown."
And then you told Connor,
I'm gonna learn Welsh.
- Oh fuck I love "The Crown."
- You were trying to speak Welsh.
And I was like, "Whoa,
whoa no one does this."
- Because it was so pretty.
Like I was just like, man.
- Thank you, it is.
So many people were like,
"Well, it sounds disgusting."
And I'm like "You should listen to it."
- Really, I think Welsh
sounds fucking dope.
- Yeah I liked, Welsh, I don't know.
- Best five in the world.
- Disgusting.
You've seen our flag?
It's just a dragon.
- Fucking UK.
- It's just a dragon.
- It's so fucking epic,
I love that flag, man.
- Just a dragon.
- It's just a dragon.
I'm actually saying it's just a dragon.
- Don't play with your stars and stripes.
I'm gonna play with a fucking dragon.
Oh yeah, I remember, sorry,
one last point about the flag.
Remember Jay said, it's so
hard to draw, no it's not.
You just draw a basic shape,
you know it's that flag, easy.
- You're so patriotic, you have a picture
of your flag above your bed.
- I did, I did, yeah.
I did in London, yeah.
- He has a picture of his like...
Is it a picture or painting?
- It is a canvas.
- Yeah, it was a canvas of the Welsh flag.
- Just to remind yourself
in the morning being like,
"Yep, still Welsh."
- 'Cause what happened mostly
when I was filming videos
on that live stream,
my wall was always in the back.
So I thought, "Well,
why not let people know
"where I'm fucking from,
"so that they stop asking me.
- I didn't know that was
your flag at the time.
I thought like, when we
were like on (indistinct)-
- Was like a Harry Potter house.
- I always saw it in the
back, like behind Connor.
I always thought it was like
some kindergarten project
that you worked on.
(all laughing)
'Cause it looked like a painting.
- From macaroni (indistinct).
- 'Cause it looked like a
painted on the little canvas,
I was like, "Huh, cute."
- Flags nowadays are
fucking boring, right?
Even back then.
- What do you mean, nowadays?
They haven't changed.
- The UK flag is a new flag before that,
It was like these weird coat of arms,
they were like fucking bad-ass
and had shit all over them
and it was from when all
the countries United.
- Yeah, it's the what's it called?
The Union Juck?
Is that what you're talking about?
- Yeah, The Union Juck.
- Are family crests just
a UK thing or is it-
- I think someone pointed
that one time and just said,
I wore a kilt to a wedding.
It's only if fair if you are
in a clan in a Scottish clan,
actually my second name
is a Scottish clan name.
And then you would get like a coat of arms
or symbols for like family association.
- That's cool.
- So, it's like this small clan.
- There's something about
clan, that just sounds cool.
Except now the like gaming
has just ruined the term, clan.
- Join my gamer clan.
- I like history, you know?
It would be pretty cool, it would be like,
"Yeah, I'm in Scottish clan.
It's bad, my second name is Scottish,
and a lot of my older, older
family is from Scotland.
We had Scottish family names.
- I don't know what it
is about the word clan,
that those are so much cooler
than like the word family,
it's like join my family, join my clan.
- Families, everyone has a family.
Clan sounds like a ghost of war.
- So you fight and you fight-
- Yeah, we die for each other.
- We die for the clan.
- You took a blood oath.
(all laughing)
'Cause like, especially in Asian culture,
like one thing that confused
Sydney so much, it's just,
we refer to everyone, as
like brother and sister.
Like, so whenever I'd introduce like-
- Some places in America do that too.
- No, but like, in Southeast Asia,
like if some stranger I've never met,
says they're my uncle I will a
hundred percent believe them.
Like, you know what I mean?
Just maybe that's another reason,
I also have never like thought of dating
another Southeast Asian,
'cause I'm like,
"It feels like I'm dating
my brother or whatever."
- Honestly, I'm exactly the same.
- I' cant date a white girl.
(all laughing)
- I'm just like, oh yeah, and like Joey,
you're just half of it, so it's okay.
- Oh yeah but am not
Southeast Asian am just Asian.
- When I first saw you on web,
when I first saw your videos,
I thought you were like
Hispanic or middle Eastern.
- Everybody says-
- You're a Bollywood star.
- Everyone links me like a Bollywood star.
And it's like this year,
like that's the thing
it's like, it's three things.
Do they have the scruffy heads?
Do they have the beard?
And is like the skin slightly brown?
That's Joey.
- In Japan, like especially
when I wear a mask
and he is wearing a mask,
people think that I'm the
one that speaks fluently
when really it's Joey.
- Yeah, I know, I hate it.
I hate it.
It's useful when you're
taking your friends around.
'Cause I can tell sometimes when Joey
just cannot be bothered
to play translator.
- I love, I love doing that sometimes.
Like I remember I took my uni friends,
my three Australian uni friends
to Kyoto for the first time.
And they'd never been to Japan.
And of course, cause I'm the only one
who can speak Japanese.
They all have been to Kyoto.
Of course, I had to play the
translator slash tour guide,
but I was like, one day I just woke up,
I was like, "Fuck, I'm so tired of this.
"You know what?
"I'm just gonna pretend I
can't speak a word of Japanese.
"They'll never know."
And we went to this really nice restaurant
and I remember the clock was ticking
and we had to order right now,
'cause the place was
closing, and it was like,
"Joey, we want this., this and this"
And I was like,
(speaks in foreign language)
they were so pissed off, but I was like,
"And now you know how fucking it feels.
"I get paid for this shit."
- No, 'cause that's why I feel
whenever I have like a
friend round in Thailand,
where it's like, you're doing it
for like a week or something.
And then it just gets tiring,
and it really dogs me.
- That'll be you.
- Tell them what I want.
(all laughing)
- All the fucking time.
- You just have to, like,
you just feel like you're hanging around
with a bunch of babies and
you just got to do everything.
'Cause I feel guilty,
whenever I ask you to do something,
'cause I know exactly how that feels.
- Like, this baby, want some milk.
- That is flickering.
- One thing I've always
wondered is that...
One of the difference, is that you guys
definitely had a point
where you kind of blew up
with your YouTube and everything,
which was like kind of
unprecedented in our community.
What was that like?
Because I've always
had this gradual growth
where I've never had a point,
when I suddenly just woke up one day
and woke up and a month later
I gained a hundred K subs
or something like that.
- I think 'cause you guys at
one point got like 250,000 subs
in one month.
And I think that's the most that-
- I think hers was bigger.
I think, yeah the max I ever got
was like 100, 5200 K in a month.
- That's when you all started collabing.
- Yeah and then I think your biggest one
was almost like 400 K a month, right?
- Yeah.
- You had like
a hundred K in a week.
- Yeah.
- It's ridiculous.
- I remember that too.
I think I said it earlier
in the podcast that like,
when I called you, I wanted
to throw up because like...
I don't know, it's like, I
knew I wanted to do YouTube,
but then once you see
that number going up,
I suddenly felt like someone pushed me
in the middle of a stage and said dance.
And then all of a sudden there was this
huge amount of pressure over a video
that I didn't even really
take that seriously and then-
- Well, 'cause I remember like you-
- Vocaloid, is it?
- Vocaloid, yeah.
- 'Cause I remember you made
like a video, which was like,
those good old like obligatory like,
"Thank you for a hundred
thousand subscribers."
- I remember, yeah.
- And then literally
a week later,
- I made a 200.
- You made a two,
thank you for 200,000 subscribers.
- I did do it 200 K and then
like I think a week later,
I was like, "Should I do the 300 K?"
I'll just say it in passing, in the video.
So yeah, no, that was really crazy.
And I still can't believe that,
that happened like over six years ago,
but I mean, maybe I wasn't really part
of the anime community itself
to really feel what
that must've felt like,
especially for you, like
where you've been in it,
like really heavily invested.
I was in AMV, which is
like a tier of its own.
So I wasn't really...
I watched like a lot of your older stuff
on that old account.
- The School Girl 101?
- Yeah, the school girl 101.
- Yeah, the School Girl 101, maybe,
I don't know, maybe I commented
on one of those old videos,
but other than that,
I was just more focused of
what I was supposed to do.
And by that point,
Joey and I had already made a decision
that we weren't going to work out.
So, I was just very much on my own thing
and he was doing his own thing, but yeah.
- 'Cause you've kind of like transitions.
You have like...
Talking to you like more recently,
you've definitely tried to transition away
from just doing anime contents.
Like was there anything
that pushed you to do that
or was it just like your
interests kind of diverged a bit?
- No, I think it's just
because like everything I go,
everything I do now, is
stuff that I'm just honestly
genuinely interested in,
and like I said before,
like anime just puts Japanese
culture in front of you.
And that's why I called
myself an Otaku channel
just because I'm not here to really give
an analysis on an anime.
There's so many other YouTubers
that I think can do the job
better than me, so.
- Even though you technically
started in that field, though.
Everything you didn't know about
was technically an analysis.
- Yeah, but like, I didn't go
doing that series to think,
like, "Oh, this is
gonna surpass everyone."
I just did it, 'cause it
was fun to do at the time.
But yeah, I don't know.
Totally forgot what you had just asked.
(all laughing)
- It's kind of funny though,
basically every anime
YouTuber we know now,
is trying to do their best
to move away from anime content.
- Okay, now I remember,
yeah so I don't know.
I think it's just also, it
comes with being a personality.
I have that privilege that I can explore
and I know that everyone's
gonna be okay with it
as long as I'm in it.
And so, I just do stuff
I genuinely like to do.
Unlike when it was anime,
I felt like there was a lot of pressure
that I have to talk about a specific anime
and then like have to talk about like,
"What's hot right now.
"What is something I can say
"that no one else has said?"
When you're just a personality
and the world's your oyster,
things are a lot more easier for you.
- I think anyone who gets like boxed
into any type of content
eventually feels like,
"Oh, I wanna do something
else for my audience."
- Yeah, clearly me.
- I think every single YouTuber
like goes through that.
Well, not every single one
but every single YouTuber
definitely thought about
doing other content
and is either,
makes a second channel to do that content
or they to use their own account.
- I guess I almost was
on that path of like,
almost becoming a top 10 channel,
with everything you
didn't know about series
and I was like...
- But it was a huge thing back then.
- It was a huge thing but I was like,
"Oh, I don't wanna keep doing this."
So slowly, I just thought
it was just natural
to just show my face.
And the face that I
decided to put myself in
was the Vocaloid one,
which I think also helped
perpetuate my subscriber count
at that point, because now
you could see who I was,
who was the person that
was talking about the shit.
So then through that,
people wanted to know me.
So then I started.
I still did Vocaloid,
but in between I had fillers of who I was.
And then eventually, I gradually got rid
of the Vocaloid stuff and just
wanted to do my own stuff.
And now that I'm in Japan, I was like,
"What anime fan doesn't
want to go to Japan?"
And what anime fan
doesn't wanna go to like,
different types of cafes.
So I was like, "I'm
gonna just do just that
"'cause I know that my
audience wants to do this stuff
"and I'm feel like I'm
kind of like their..."
What is it?
Not gateway and I'm like-
- Introduction.
- Yeah, introduction,
they're living vicariously through me,
I guess, through this content.
And yeah, I don't know,
that's just the way I've-
- Yeah, I get that,
'cause especially one thing
that makes me uncomfortable
with my own content,
is when people kind of see us as like say,
ambassadors of anime where like,
I'm just a guy who just
has an opinion, but-
- What did the gigs last call
us again, The Heroes of Anime?
(all laughing)
It makes me uncomfortable when people
are like taking my opinion
really, really seriously,
when I say like-
- Like your word is gospel.
- Yeah, like I like X or like
Y and people were just like,
"Yo Gignac said it, he ruined this,
"humanity or something."
And it's just like, "Dude,
I know as much as...
"I'm just me me, I know
as much as anyone else."
- It really says something
when like the audience
takes your opinion more seriously,
than you take your own opinion.
- Yeah, exactly, I feel that way
with just not my content
but with the Trash Taste as well,
and some people will take
what we sell on Trash Taste
very seriously, and sometimes we do talk
about serious topics,
but when it's just something
about anime or something,
I'm just like, "Come on, dude."
- Its like who cares.
- But one thing I have noticed,
like I have to ask though, True Crime.
- Every girls (indistinct) topic.
- So, recently, we've caught up
and you started talking
about your newest obsession
and some of your new contents, which are,
it's very true crime mask.
You know, you've released,
we've recently released a
video on the, Otaku Killer.
I found it funny because
we hadn't talked for awhile
and Sydney also very much
went into this phase.
And she's like serial
killers for a lot of times,
but now, it seems like every
girl is into True Crimes
and True Crime Podcast.
- So you wanna see from
a female's perspective
of why the fuck this is a thing?
- Why?
- What happens?
- I like True Crime and
I don't really know why
I like true crime.
I just find it real life-
- I find that shit fascinating as fuck.
But there's a difference
between liking the content
and it being the first thing
I watch in the morning.
- I did ask one of the girls, sorry,
before you answer that, you wanna...
This made me laugh a lot.
I asked why do you like True Crime?
They were like, Oh, it's like
preparation to defend myself.
This happens, and I'm like,
"Yo, how often are you gonna
come across a serial killer
who specifically duct tapes,
like 10 victims together, come on.
- 'Cause it was funny.
Cause like, being with Sydney for so long,
she's from Wisconsin.
And one of the things
that apparently proud of,
is that there are so many killers
that have come from Wisconsin.
- Isn't it like the number
one state with the most amount
of serial killers?
- You guys come to Vermont,
we have the most sex offenders in Vermont.
(all laughing)
- So, she had always
prided herself on like,
"I'm the serial killer in Tokyo."
And then suddenly in like
the past year or two,
every girl started getting
into serial killers
and True Crime.
And I'm just here thinking,
where did this come from?
Where did it start?
- Honestly I feel like just
the blow up has happened
because true crime YouTubers,
specifically criminal psychology,
just started getting recommended
and it's like, awoken something.
I think we all really...
Like as for me,
I never thought of this as a girl thing
until like you told me
when we met up and then I was like,
"No, that's not a thing."
And then the next day,
I just remember like Charlotte texted me.
She's like, "Yes, you're coming up.
"We're gonna watch the True Crime stuff."
I said, "Yeah, Oh my fucking
God, this is a thing."
So, for me personally,
I always thought it just came
from me really liking horror.
And me taking psychology,
The reason I loved serial killer stories,
is not what they did,
but it's like the psychology
that goes through it
'cause serial killers,
a lot of them are very intelligent
and the shit that they have
to do to get to that point,
it's almost like the more I read,
the more I don't want to think it's real.
It seems like it's just so-
- It's stranger than fiction.
- It's so strange,
so that's where, that's
why I liked True Crime.
And then like with,
the YouTube channel criminal psychology,
I just like it that
someone had the patience
to take like the raw interrogation
and break down why they
ask these questions.
'Cause you can't help,
but applaud some of
these like interrogators
that they do this for a
living and they know exactly
what questions to ask you.
Not for you to answer, but to just see
how you're gonna respond.
Like sometimes they leave you alone
just for you to stew in your
own thoughts and I just...
And Garnt was laughing at this
'cause I was like, I sometimes
feel like when I watch it,
I'm the one being interrogated.
Like I feel like I have to
lock myself out of this.
I'm just watching the fucking thing.
But yeah, so then I started
the True Crime stuff in Japan
because in Japan I've always just thought,
there's always that thing,
everyone knows that crime
is really low in Japan.
But when shit happens in Japan,
it's from like zero to a hundred.
It's like in America, it's nothing like...
This is weird.
Take this with a grain of salt, normal,
like guy kills girlfriend
for cheating on him.
It's not that, it's like,
I'm going to like burn
everyone alive and post it all
like on 2Chan, just 'cause I feel like it.
And it's like, nothing
builds up between that.
So my True Crime stuff is like,
I wanna look back at what the
fuck happened to this guy.
- Just like a fucking episode
of "Black Mirror", sometimes.
- Essentially, and I love "Black Mirror."
- I think it seems like, in,
in the U.S. they might assume
that it could be something
bad that's happened.
"Cause crime doesn't happen that much.
And then the police
never would like think,
that this guy might be
going after children
or something like that.
And they also...
I've also noticed that with
at least Japanese like True Crime,
a lot of people in Japan
don't talk about it
"cause they don't like it.
- Its taboo.
- Yeah, it's like, no, but
don't forget it, let it be.
So it's pretty interesting
seeing like people,
I like yourself trying to
find stuff out about it.
'Cause it's like so buried
'cause they don't wanna talk about it.
- Pretty much, and so-
- And before you go on, sorry.
I completely forgot, I was gonna say it.
- Again, I totally get
the obsession in that.
And I totally get like, watching
these interrogation stuff,
super fucking fascinating.
- But you wanna know why its all girls?
- Yeah but like, this is the
difference again between,
looking at an interrogate
doing his job and being like,
"Wow, the psychology behind
this is fucking fascinating."
And fucking waking up
like seven in the morning
and you just from the
living room, you just hear-
- [Both] His arms were cut off.
(indistinct chatter)
And I go in, I'm like, "What
the fuck is happening?"
You're just like sitting at
the table, eating cereal.
Like it's nothing,
- That's just our mornings.
I was like bonding of
Joey and it's weird like,
"Did you wake up to True Crime Podcasts?
"And you're listening
to True Crime Podcasts?"
'Cause I do.
- Yeah and just having this-
- I'm just imagining,
it's like the sunlight's coming through,
the birds are chirping,
it's a lovely day, and you just hear like,
"And so he brutally murdered these girls,
"in the most gruesome way
possible, here's how they did it.
- Number 10.
- Yeah, number 10.
- Remember we even went up to the North
and we were meeting Sharla and then like,
you guys wanted to go
to bed, but she's, like,
"Hey guys, I'm gonna go upstairs.
"Does anyone wanna watch the
True Crime thing with me?"
I'm like, "I'll do it."
And then she's like,
"All right, let's go."
And so literally you and Luke are just-
- Yeah me and my friend was just like,
"All right, see you
later, have a nice day."
- I don't know, it's just like,
because it's just people
talking and well, no, I'm not-
- Yeah, but then, at the same time,
it's the, double edge thing of like,
you know what the girls will be like,
"Yeah, we love watching True Crime."
But then when you tell
a girl that, you know,
you watch the two hour Fredrik Knudsen,
Down the Rabbit Hole video,
they'd be like, "Why
would you watch that?"
- Bro they're amazing?
What do you mean?
- Meanwhile, it's like,
"I don't wanna watch a two
hour Down the Rabbit Hole."
It's like, "I am gonna go with
a six hour interrogation."
It's like, "What?"
- With some guy commentating
over (indistinct) like button.
- Like, what's his name,
I bet he's thinking about other girls,
the boys watching super
monkey (indistinct).
(all laughing)
- Did you watch the Netflix
documentary about the hotel?
It's about like the-
- Yeah, "The Hotel,"
where they find the girl
in the water tank.
- The water tank one.
- Yeah, that's a really famous case.
- I really like that
one because it was like,
you thought like it's about this case.
And they suddenly were like,
"Yeah, so about these redditors man."
It was really cool, 'cause
they actually like...
'Cause it was quite recent.
It was like giving you the
perspective of the cops
at the time, and they were
getting so frustrated.
The people online kept trying
to fucking solve the case.
Wouldn't stop coming up with
crazy ass conspiracy theories.
And it made me think, I was like,
"Oh yeah, it must be so
annoying being a policeman now,
"where everyone is trying to do your job."
And it's like, "Release
every detail to us."
- I was gonna watch that documentary
and I brought it off Tokyo, I was like,
"Oh, they made a
documentary about this case.
"And she was like, "I already know."
- Yeah, she already knows the details.
- So I never ended up watching it.
- I think I got to ask that
'cause if you consume a lot,
like where's the line with
YouTubers talking about
real life cases.
- What do you mean?
- Like because do you
think it's free game,
they can say whatever they want
conspiracy theories and all
they can talk about it,
'cause it's like kind of
rough because it's like,
you only have X amount of facts.
How far are you allowed to talk about?
- So I went pretty fucking
deep with the Otaku killer one
with that one, I-
- But you aren't presenting
any theories, right?
Like you just told the case, like facts.
- Yeah, when it comes
to presenting theories,
I would say that like it's, I don't know.
'Cause for me, I wanna go over cases
that are already closed by that point.
And it's been a substantial
amount of time since that.
- You don't wanna
accidentally solve a case.
- I don't know if you guys knew about...
You've probably heard of
that Twitter killer in Japan.
I didn't even wanna touch that
'cause that was still going on
and I didn't wanna fuck it up.
Like with my video, you know.
- I feel so bad for these...
Like in the documentary as well,
like the cops and also the families.
Like this whole documentary
was going on about this hotel.
You should watch it by the way.
What is it called?
Do you guys know?
- No, I don't.
I don't know what it's called.
- I'm sure it's a good documentary.
My problem with a lot of
Netflix documentaries,
I've found nowadays,
is that it feels like,
they drag it out so much.
I remember, 'cause I knew the
basic details of this case
because I've heard it
from like second hand,
just hearing Sidney
listen to different cases.
So, I knew the case and I was like,
"Okay, maybe I'll find out a
bit more about the details."
And then I watched 60 minutes
and the first episode,
where just literally
building up the hotel itself
and I'm just like, "I
already know what happens."
- Who cares?
- I don't care about this.
We get it, it's a bad hotel
and they focus on this
couple, who's just...
There's this British couple,
whose like staying in the hotel
and I'm like, "I don't
give a shit about a couple.
" Just give me the damn facts please."
That's been my big problem.
- It was really interesting
'cause it was like the only one
that looked at the online critiques
or online people who
are trying to solve it
in like a critical way.
'Cause there was another
one that was called like,
"Don't Fuck With Cats."
I love that one.
- I love, "Don't Fuck With Cats."
- I liked it but I could not fucking
stand the woman.
- Stand the girl.
Oh my God!
She was ending it like,
"We're just a couple of guys online
"about to solve a murder."
- No, it wasn't even
that it was just like,
"We're just like internet
nerds, just trying to like..."
It was like, Oh God.
- I understand it like,
the modern cases and
a lot of (indistinct).
- But I like the way, "Don't
Fuck With Cats," builds it up.
- Yes, they keep building up well.
Like it doesn't...
They don't even show
you Luka Magnotta's face
until the very end,
even though they usually could have,
because they want you to like
see everyone's perspective,
like that was involved in this.
- No that one was crazy
and it would have been so much better,
if they had just replaced that woman
with just a standard
narrator or something.
No offense to the woman.
It was infuriating how
she was just talking about
cats being murdered.
And then she was like,
"Whoa, that was wacky.
"And then we found him
killing other people."
- Or if she's pushing
or if she could have just
stuck with the facts.
- It was the acting term.
- It's like you don't
need to act on something
that is about murder
and cats being killed,
like I don't need this shit-
- I don't need to know the
personality of the presenter.
Like just give me the facts.
- I think, one of the big
reasons I could never get
into True Crime or like
I've never been able
to fully invest in it, is just
because it feels to me like,
I know it's not an intentional,
but it feels like to me,
it's you kind of view
this as a fictional story.
You view it as like an
entertainment based thing.
I remember watching
"Don't Fuck With Cats,"
and very, very fascinating story.
That's not what I'm saying,
and they had a segment on this,
but it just feels for
me a little bit wrong.
I just feel a little bit dirty when I know
that I'm watching this for entertainment.
When I know that someone
got fucking murdered,
that this is like some family's lives
as perhaps has been ruined by this.
And you know, all the
attention is on the murderer.
And I know they did do like a segment on,
how nobody remembers the victim
and that's just the fucking ugly truth.
And that's the big line for
me when it comes to True Crime
and watching like a good horror movie
or a good like fictional story,
is I can't, like wash away this feeling
that I'm just kinda
like listening to this,
like, I don't know what the right word is,
but it's just like, I'm
viewing this real life event,
this real life tragic event
as an entertainment piece.
'Cause that's what it is.
It's an entertainment piece
and that's why I've not
been able to get into it.
- So would you prefer it
then say hypothetically,
if they like, properly
go over like the family?
- Like I don't know,
what the right way to go
about it, it's just...
- Maybe there is no right way.
- I don't know if there is right,
'cause it's just my mental block
because I find something
like, for example,
"Monster" fascinating, 'cause it's like
a really deep character study
on, what it means, are you born evil?
Or is evil something
you learn along the way?
But the reason I'm in it, the
reason I can invest in it,
is because I know it's a fiction.
There's that's barrier
that I know that no one's-
- Its like a moral barrier,
- It's kind of like, I
guess telling a story
about wars and stuff there as well.
There's tons of death in that.
And that's just because
more often than not,
you're just used to tell stories
about stuff that had happened
and stuff in real life.
Even though they have to...
unfortunately I think at times stories,
do have to be boiled down in a way
that will make people listen.
So, it does almost feel
like you say like, I mean,
I understand why this
story needs to be sad
and why it almost does feel
wrong that it's entertainment,
but I understand completely
why it is that way.
For human nature, we've
always been telling stories
about horrific things
'cause they are stories.
- And then the stories
and sometimes it feels...
I don't know if wrong is the right word,
but it just feels weird to
have it presented in a way
that is entertaining.
- I will admit that the
modern-like gold rush
of True Crime is getting
a little bit weird.
Like its trying to feel a
little bit uncomfortable
with how much stuff is being milked
and how much it's being
like kitchen nightmares,
editing ask, and stuff,
it's like, it used to go
from these are the facts
of the case to now.
It's like, "Mary didn't know
what was coming, but it came."
- The points is if you just
present the facts of a case,
it's boring, it's fucking boring.
And I especially feel this
whenever I watch like,
American news broadcast versus
like British news broadcast
because British news broadcasts,
are like the most boring
news broadcast ever.
And then in America, I
remember the first time
I went to America,
turned on the news and it felt
like I was watching a movie.
- Like I did ask, I
didn't notice sometimes
if I was watching the news in America
or I was watching an episode
of the cops right away,
'cause it's edited in the exact same way
where it's just like a little too...
And that, I guess kind of boils down
to like that whole genre of films
of like exploitation films.
It's like, some people find
it really fucking fascinating.
While others are like,
"That's not really cool."
- I also really like documentaries
because I like to figure out.
I'm like, "All right, who they
trying to get me to root for?
"What are they---"
'Cause there's someone telling a story.
And they've Kathleen picked
out all these interviews,
Kathleen asked people questions
to present in a certain way,
and it's fun.
Sometimes I like watching
it just to figure out
like why are they trying to
make me think of this way?
Why are they trying to get
me to have this opinion
of the next character,
its really interesting.
- I guess that's what
made Tiger King so good.
- It was a video by like
Quintin reviews about it,
about documentaries, it was really good.
- Because, I think what
made me realize this,
is watching "Don't Fuck
With Cats," where...
What was his name again?
- Luka Magnotta.
- Luka Magnotta, Magnotta.
- Just say Luka.
- Luka, where all he wanted
was to have the spotlights
and what was to have the attention.
And, I remember at the end,
thinking, "Oh, he fucking succeeded.
"This is everything that he wanted."
"This is literally like
dark night joke a moment."
- He got a four part Netflix
documentary series, dude.
He was the real winner out of this.
It just felt, dirty to me.
I don't, I was just like,
"Damn, I don't know."
- I guess, when his sole
aim was to get attention
and then he gets it.
That is kind of yeah.
- I mean, I just think it all just comes
from the human nature of
like looking at a car crash
that you can't look away from.
Like we love to torture ourselves.
- We're simple beings.
- One other thing I would
do wanna know is that,
because I wake up to this
and I hear a different story
or like I hear a new episode every time.
How, many stories have you listened to?
How many, like how deep
does the True Crime well go.
That's what I want to know.
- Yeah because I feel like,
the gentlemen have only
stepped into the kiddie pool.
- I'm sick of it because
I've watched so many now,
that I can feel like
the formula being full.
It always starts right.
They're like, "Timmy
was a little different,
"but we never thought he would
never do anything like this."
And then it'd be like,
it cut to the victim.
And it's like, "She was only
good things, the victim."
And then cuts back to the thing it's like,
"And then something weird
started to happen at the school."
And it's like, alright,
okay we get it, we get it.
He was okay, he was weird, right.
But like, they would never say this shit
unless he was a serial
killer, you know what I mean?
Like it's when they find out,
is that they only remember bad things.
Everyone always says the same shit
about every serial killer,
it drives me insane.
- Is that true?
- After you've watched
like 10 documentaries,
you feel like you're going
insane, watching more.
'Cause you're like,
"These feel all the same."
- I feel like that with a
lot of, especially like...
Again, I'm making this sound
like it's fucking film,
but like Western crime,
like it starts to feel
like the same thing.
But I mean, I don't know.
I'm sorry, I feel again,
I mean, with my series,
like the one in Japan,
every case isn't really
the same in my opinion,
'cause I mean, I don't know though,
at least I literally have-
- No, no, no, I wasn't saying
about the case of the same,
it's how the documentary
makers present the-
- The story.
- Well, the thing is like
with True Crime Podcasts
or True Crime YouTube
videos that I can see,
it's not always like a documentary is lit.
Like she's just listing out
the events and the facts.
- Particularly like that.
- I mean, 'cause to me it feels like,
I've seen like top 10 lists
of like the weirdest crimes
or top unsolved crimes.
- We have top 10 deaths caught on camera.
- My favorites are the top 10
breakdowns in courtroom cases.
- Top 10 unsolved crime.
Like you, you go through one on top 10-
- So, what dictates number seven,
over number eight?
Like I don't understand,
they're both horrible.
- And like, I've heard of a few
and you get to a point where,
it's like asking people
what their top 10 anime is,
after you've seen enough anime,
you see the same cases,
you know what the say?
You know what everyone's like.
- I love that about...
Go on, sorry.
- You know what the
mainstream anime are, right?
'Cause that's why I feel like,
"What are your top 10 crime cases?
What are the ones that stick to your mind?
List them off, chill style.
- Oh my God.
- Number 10.
- You want me to list?
- Like off the top of your head?
What's your favorite?
- What are the, some
of the ones that stick
out to your mind?
- Well, I literally have
like a bookmark list,
like this fucking big on my computer.
- What is your favorite
True Crime documentary?
Like it comes to mind when you think.
- God, legit, like "Don't Fuck with Cats",
is perfect to me, honestly.
But honestly that was perfect.
Besides like the, CEG
the fact that you know,
this is a close case and yet
you feel like it's still open.
Like, I dunno the whole presentation.
- I love those videos where it's like,
it presents itself like a rudy
big mystery and that like,
they let like two episodes
in and then they present like
what actually happened,
like the very plausible,
very simple explanation and then the life.
But some people don't believe that.
I mean, it's like 30 more minutes
of like complete auto nonsense.
- And it's just like theories
that don't make sense.
- It's complete bullshit,
it's like you already have the explanation
just accepted that it's
boring like real life is.
- Or because like weirdly enough,
you didn't really like Tiger King.
- No, I actually really didn't like it.
- Which is weird because you
think that the fact that,
at the end of the day, it's a true crime.
It's a true crime story,
that's just a little bit unique.
- Its a crime that any of those
people got to be filmed and-
- But like, you didn't like it.
I thought you'd like that.
- Yeah, I don't know.
What was it that like you didn't like
about Tiger King that you
liked about everything else?
- I don't know maybe
I've just seen and heard,
so much fucked up stories that like,
it was just not entertaining to me.
I was like, "Oh yeah."
- You've literally just numbed yourself.
I honestly think it's probably that.
- We should start watching
a playground argument
just unfold, but with guns and tigers.
- I didn't like about Tiger King,
was the fact that I couldn't
believe these were real people.
Like I thought they were playing.
I dead ass thought first two episodes,
I thought they were playing a character.
- I, watched it all and I thought,
"Fuck I just wasted all my time."
(Joey and Aki laughing)
- For nothing.
- I'm just surprised how popular it got.
I didn't expect-
- I just really appreciate,
especially I'm rolling back
to that YouTube channel
criminal psychology, just because
it takes a lot of research
to understand why this
interrogation is being played out
the way it is, it's not
just question and answer.
It's like, they're trying
to like create pressure
for you, for you to fucking just confess.
- I guess, because you have
a psychology background,
It's like more instant for you.
- Feel like even without
a psychology background.
I think that's just
fascinating the way that
it's just presented, they
explain it like you're five
and I don't know, like
my heart starts racing.
Like the closer they get
to getting to the person-
- To get that confession out.
- Yeah, to get that
confession, I was like-
- Here it comes, here it comes!
- I have noticed that there is like,
reaction YouTubers to interrogations.
Yeah, yeah, there's people who
like to watch interrogations
and give their thoughts on that thing.
And I'm like this is weird.
- That's going too far.
- And like, "Oh my God, what!".
- I don't imagine anyone
like, doing all of that stuff.
I just like, watch that thing.
- That's like reacting to public hanging.
It's like, "Whoa, that just happened!"
- It's like shocked
face underscore dot PNG.
We all have that PNG file.
- It's bizarre, how...
- It is bizarre that it
has been like commodified.
- I was wondering what the word is,
it was like entertainmentfied,
is that a word?
I was like, I'm sure there is a word.
- I actually had no idea that
you guys had talked about
The True crime thing on your podcast.
So when I uploaded the Otaku killer video,
like half my comments were like,
"Wow, the podcast was right about you."
I said, "Well, no, I don't.
"What, Joey, what the fuck did you say?"
- I called you out.
- That's all right.
- Yeah, I dunno, I think obviously,
due to the fact that
there's more mobile phones
and that things are being recorded more
for like the evidence purposes in court,
and so there's just more and
more stuff getting released.
- Public journalism.
- And this is the side of the crime
that the public never saw.
You barely ever hear about this
through like stories from cops,
which obviously was
presented with full of bias
and stuff like this.
So I think it's just
like a renaissance almost
of the public being given access
to crimes for good and bad.
'Cause you know, now
those people get outraged
all the time for stuff that
cops do rightfully serve,
so shouldn't they pull.
Like, and so it's kind of...
I wonder if this'll be an
ongoing thing where you know,
crime from now onwards
has to be put in mind
or I'm like, "Huh, what's
the YouTube comment gonna say
"about the way that they are."
I wonder if there's gonna
be crimes in future-
- What it there's like
serial killers who are like,
"I wonder, what clickbait
they gonna use for my crime."
- I wonder now, like
if I'm in an interview,
I'm being interrogated,
I might think, "Well,
this might be an issue."
"But I'm on a good show."
I wonder, it's really...
I guess there like sensitive
ways that like, yeah,
We've been desensitized to it,
but also it's a system
that hasn't been built
to be exposed to the public.
- Yeah, I don't think it's just that,
but because I think
like another big thing,
is that the reality,
I mean, the barrier between
like reality and fiction
has kind of like been slowly broken down
because sometimes we
kind of view social media
as entertainment nowadays.
So, like council culture is
like a big thing nowadays.
And I feel like with so many YouTubers
making like apology videos
and outing other people like this,
there is a reason people do that.
There is a personal reason people do that,
but we got to admit that
through the vast majority
of the public,
this is just watching,
this is just entertainment.
This is just watching the high school...
This is listening to high
school drama and gossip.
And like, it's what has slowly
turned into where it's...
Our entertainment has just
become other people's reality.
This is our modern day reality TV.
- I can definitely see the difference.
I've mentioned this to a couple of people,
but it's still only just
seems like a few years ago,
when the internet and
real life, they were just,
there was such a thick
wall between two of them.
Like you could tell that
anything that was said
on the internet was not taken personally.
And then like being in
reality, it was whatever.
But now, the news gets like
half of their shit from Twitter.
And reality and the internet has fused
so heavily into each other
that everything you post,
that's the kind of person you are.
At least that's what-
- It legit like cyril experiments lane,
like straight up call for (indistinct).
- Essentially yeah.
- It did.
- Like 10 years ago, it would be like,
"Oh, did you catch the
latest 'Love Island'"
Or "Big Brother?"
"Did you hear what X did?"
And now nowadays it's more like,
"Yo, did you see that apology video?
"Yo, that was saucier."
- Did you see that Tweet along that dude?
- That was a yikes no Tweet land.
And it's just like, okay.
And we are kind of commodifying
other people's drama
in that case.
- Essentially yeah, and people's lives
are being ruined over just people
trying to create conspiracies
out of just posts.
Some of those posts are just...
Actually a lot of those
posts are just twisted
to make these conspiracies
of anonymous people
that honestly don't give a shit about you
and it ruins careers.
It ruins lives, it ruins
people's mental health.
And I feel like, I don't know,
I kind of hope at some point
that that line of anonymity,
not caring about other
people on the internet,
like where's the line gonna get drawn?
- I don't know because
I don't see it stopping
and that's the problem.
And one of the biggest
things I see now is like,
it doesn't matter how right
you are in the court of law,
'cause what's more important nowadays,
is the court of public opinion.
And it's a really unhealthy
way to think about things
because sometimes I do feel
that there is like
sometimes online witch hunts
and sometimes peak, you know,
it's so broken down to basic
mob mentality nowadays,
and it can get really dangerous, so-
- That's why I tell people that anyone
who wants to like be a YouTuber, streamer
or any influencer on the internet,
it takes thick skin, a lot of thick skin.
You have to always be
prepared for the inevitable,
that there will always
be a community out there
who like you'll be a scapegoat
to someone, anything,
and everything you do and
say, will just be wrong,
like to these people.
And they will wait for
you to fuck up so badly,
where they can finally drag you down.
And I don't know, I just
feel like that's one
of the biggest reasons why
there is this whole side
to my personal life that I want
nothing to do with YouTube,
because then at least, you know,
I wanna be able-
- 'Cause everything's
being monitored, right?
- Essentially, yeah.
I feel like people who get like,
counseled really badly on the internet,
it affects their own
personal lives to the point
like they cannot live
normally, like there's...
I don't know, I feel like on the internet,
it's if you make a mistake,
you deserve to die kind of mentality
and there's no second chances.
- The thing about
council culture nowadays,
is that we're trying to counsel people
who say don't deserve their
famous or something like that,
but it's gotten to the point
where if someone is getting counseled,
People who are not even in their circles
or hear and talk about it.
Most of the people, some of the people
that have this big apology or counsel,
or was getting counseled,
I have never heard of these people,
until they got counseled.
Like I have nothing to
do with that industry
or in their circle.
But as soon as they're getting counseled,
as soon as their drama, suddenly
it's literally everywhere.
Literally everyone has
to have an opinion on it.
- And they kind of throw around that name,
as if you're the weird one for
not having an opinion on it.
It's like, I've never heard of this dude.
But people like,
"What's your opinion on
them getting counseled?"
It's like, "Fuck, I just knew
about them five minutes ago."
- You know what's sad about all of this,
is like when someone gets counseled,
and eventually Twitter
does kind of the math org
of seeing where it came from
and the person that came from,
then let's say that that influencer,
that got counseled finally
calls out the person
who started it all,
that person, all they have to do,
is just close their account,
and run off as if it never happened.
But then the influencer
has the damage leftover
and has to deal with trying
to repair their reputation
over something that probably
wasn't even a big deal
in the first place.
- 'Cause, the big problem I see,
is that the big difference between this
and say reality TV shows,
is that people signed
up to be fucking clowns
on reality TV shows.
You know what I mean?
They knew what they
were getting paid to be-
- They were getting paid to be clowns.
- Yeah, they're getting paid to be clowns
and they signed themselves
up to be like commodified
and viewed as a piece of entertainment.
But like nowadays, literally
that could be anyone
with a social media account,
that could be anyone who has an online-
- Without their permission.
- At all and some people have
done some pretty bad stuff,
but like what the problem nowadays is,
is that I feel like even if
someone did something bad,
I can't help but feel that some people
are just looking for their
five minutes of fame,
even if something bad did
really happened to them.
And I'm not like,
I'm really hoping this doesn't come off
that I'm trying to victim
blame or something like that,
because that's really not
what I'm trying to say,
because it feels like...
It can sometimes feel like not every case,
but in some cases that people
are just doing this for the cloud,
they're doing this 'cause they know
they can get some attention out of it.
And that's what-
- And people are gonna rag
on about them for a while.
But then they probably in
the back of their heads,
they probably know by a week,
its going back to normal.
- And that's why we start ending up
like fucking ranking
apology videos, be like,
"Yo, he fucking slammed on this person
"in the apology video."
- I do love the idea
for the apology video.
- But you gotta remember these
are people's fucking lives
that we're judging and it's not
about, who's actually right,
it's about who can present
their case the best.
And, it's about pleasing
the court of public opinion
rather than being behind the scenes,
he was actually morally, right.
- Like honestly, I'm just gonna say,
I really hate how there's
like a sense of humanity
just taken away from us.
Like the moment that you become
someone in the public eye,
like you can't make mistakes,
you are not given second chances.
And every mistake you've made that is you.
And you're a piece of shit.
And there's no redemption,
there's no room for
redemption on the internet.
So that's why, I'm just gonna say-
- As if every human being is perfect-
- I'm just gonna say it right here,
just in case I know
what's going to happen.
Like I'm going to make a mistake
and I'm going to learn from it.
And it's whether up to you guys,
if you want to forgive me or not,
but it's through those mistakes,
that you can change as a person.
And I feel like it's the most basic thing
that everyone knows.
And yet we just kind of blow it off
like it's nothing because you know,
we're public figures that ruled the...
For some reason does not
apply to us or whatever.
So I don't know, I've always just wanted
to kind of get that out.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't
mean any harm to anyone
and I'm sure if I've ever made a mistake,
I'd like the opportunity to fix it.
It is very scary knowing that chance
might not be given to me.
- You're like always on
the line of that basically.
- It's fucking scary,
how much a mob can turn
and there are people,
it seems like the opposite of
the way things should work,
'cause whenever someone gets outed,
it's guilty until proven innocent.
And it shouldn't be like that,
but that's just the way
the mob mentality works.
- There's just not enough
people who are like,
"Hey, why don't we just
wait and see what happens.
- Yeah, exactly.
Because 90% of people are
like frothing at their mouth
ready for the drama.
And then there's just that
10% of people who are like,
"Yeah, I mean, we could just wait
"and hear both sides, maybe."
It's unfortunate that-
- No, I don't wanna wait.
I want something to happen now.
- Its unfortunate that
most people's reaction
to X person to this X thing is that,
"Oh my God, let's go for it."
Instead of being like, "Let's
just wait, see what they say?
"And kind of hear their point."
- I think coming from like
being more personality based
on YouTube, it sucks that like...
It seems like the only thing
that anyone has to go by,
is literally just the videos I've done
or any posts that I've made.
And it's like, again,
there's every single
person on the internet
has like a whole life
that is completely different.
You can't, base a person off
of just what their post is.
You know I see some of
the weirdest shit like,
"Oh, Aki was in a video with that person.
"She didn't look very
happy or like that person.
"Oh, did you see the way
"that they looked at that other person?
Or, "The way that Joey
just did this to his nose?"
I thought like, who the fuck cares?
- Was it your video I
was in where I was like,
I was just being me and
letting you guys talk.
- All the comments were like,
"Man, Connor looks really annoyed,
I'm like, "That was just him."
- Maybe, Connor has the same problem I do,
which is we just have really
bad resting bitch face
- I have really bad resting bitch face-
- Me too.
- And people think I'm angry all the time.
I'm just British.
(all laughing)
I hate it but what can I do?
- Yeah, I know, it's
just my listening face.
That's why I've just
been super transparent
that also I'm introverted.
And I just want to listen.
- Its that whole mentality
of the whole fucking,
"I know your life better
than you know your life."
- Like I think every-
- I hate that you have
to justify any of that
in the first place.
- Every issue we've met,
is like different steps
away from that personality,
a personality that they share.
Some people are exactly the
way that they show themselves.
I'd like to think I'm
pretty fucking spot on
to how I present myself.
There's some people who
are like a hundred percent,
could not be more different
from the person they present.
- It's like two different people.
- Right, right and it's kind of,
you don't know if that is really them.
So, don't assume that that's how they act
a hundred percent of the time.
Obviously, I think one thing that probably
is for most people,
except for like Sydney,
is that they're not as energetic.
They're not as high
intensity as they are shown.
- I think there's a
reason for that though,
and this is also like
applying to me as well.
- People have had that
much fucking energy.
- No and you know what Connor
just said applies to me.
It's like, I will be really
outspoken on my video,
but like I did in the
fortune teller video,
I literally just showed what I'm-
- Yeah, you're fucking different
to how you are presented.
- Yeah, I'm very different
with how I am with someone else.
But that's because at the end of the day,
we were just kids that I sound like
that fucking girl from
"Don't Fuck With Cats," but-
- We were just-
- We were just a couple of kids.
- We were just, like
people that had a camera
and just happened to get a
following on the internet.
But at the end of the day,
we're still in that
room just by ourselves.
And when the doors are
closed and no one's there,
we have the confidence to say
exactly what's on our mind.
But you know, I feel like
everyone has that problem.
Like, you have a lot that you wanna say,
but the moment like
someone is in front of you,
you can't get it out,
you know what I mean?
So I don't know.
- 'Cause I feel-
- I, oh, go, on.
- I feel like one of
the biggest toxic talk
that the most toxic mentality
that's kind of being
brought up with something,
newer generation, especially
raised on the web,
is that they feel like they're
privileged to know everything
about a certain case or
so old people's lives,
especially when it comes to
a drama, they feel entitled.
Like they deserve to know
everything that happened,
even though it's got
nothing to do with them.
- You know, what I really
hate that people do,
is when people are forced to
influencers to be friends,
you know what I mean?
Like, so I-
- Why are you not friends with so-and-so?
It's like, "Because I
don't wanna be friends
"with so-and-so."
- 'Cause I'm a picky person in general.
Like you can't force me to like someone,
like, it's gonna show on camera.
You like, you can tell
when two YouTubers...
I think you said this earlier,
like that's our first time
meeting or we just don't...
We're not close and it shows,
but then you're happy that
we're finally together,
but I don't know, it's just-
- Worse than that, is I
haven't met any people
who have done this, but
other YouTubers who use
that pressure from the
public to force someone,
to being friends.
To read at you a bunch in
a way that like, kind of-
- Sorry, I wasn't understanding.
- So for example, another YouTuber
who wants to be friends with you,
so what the other one just
keep tweeting at you publicly.
- Or they get their fans to tweet at you.
- But then if you tweet at them publicly,
like the fans reply,
it's like they are kind
of twisting your arm.
- It's a little bit
worse than the fan base
of that person tweeting back.
- I mean, I understand why fans do it.
More often than not,
they might like to tweet creators as well,
so I get it why they wanna
see people collaborate.
But it's quite frustrating
when someone in your position
who should know better, does it.
Like, tweeting at someone is not...
I'm not saying YouTubers
can't tweet at each other,
but there is a way that
some YouTubers do it
and the frequency at which they do it,
which is obviously an
attempt. To like, "Hey-"
- There is nothing wrong
with like tweeting.
- "Hey, follow me, follow me back,
"let's talk., let's be friends."
Yeah, there's nothing
wrong with two YouTubers
tweeting at each other.
I tweet at YouTubers all the fucking time,
but what's annoying, is when
every time it has nothing to do
with anything, I'm just
like tweeting being like,
"Ha ha, yeah, cool."
And the 17 responses being like,
"Collab, collab, collab."
- You always do the same thing,
when you talk about collabs,
you do, collab (laughs).
- It legitimately sounds like
a bunch of seals at sea wall.
This just fucking collab, collab, collab.
It's like, no, that's not.
- It appears like you're a jelly bag.
(all laughing)
Yeah, like no, you
sometimes like you can tell
when a YouTuber is really
trying to force their way
into your circle by getting
their fans to do it.
- Not many people do it but-
- I've seen it happen.
- I've definitely seen that happen.
But yeah, what's another thing on YouTube?
Oh yeah, I saw this like
a really long time ago,
I think with just Joey and Garnt.
But one thing that is-
(indistinct chatter)
(laughs) I don't think
you were there that's why.
But you know how like,
a lot of YouTubers say,
"I don't care about the views
"and the views don't mean anything."
I think it's a load of
like shit at some point,
because it's okay to care about your views
because that's like being at a job
and caring how many hours you're getting,
how much you're getting paid.
It's okay to care about how
many views you're getting.
But like also not being a dick about it.
- I think the important thing,
is to think about the views
after the video has been made.
People, if you're going into a video,
with the views in mind of like,
"What's gonna get the views?"
In a way that's-
- You're doing it purely for the viewers.
- Unhealthy obsession way not like...
'Cause sometimes I'll think of a topic
and I'm like, "This is a popular topic.
"This is probably gonna
have some interests,
"but I'm not thinking like
this needs to get views."
Or, "It's done."
Or I'm not like, "I think
that I'll look after."
And if it does well,
I'm like, "Sick."
If it does bad, I'm
like, "Well, that sucks."
But onto the next thing
'cause what are you gonna do?
Sit here and fucking mourn?
- 'Cause, I feel like what
I've meant when I said that,
'cause I have said, I don't
care about the views before.
- Everyone's had that obligatory.
- I wanna defend myself.
- I'm gonna defend myself.
- Honestly, I think we've
all said that at some point.
- Everyone has made that
obligatory update video
where they're like,
"Guys, I'm just doing it
"because I love doing YouTube,
"I don't care about the views."
- I've, kept the saying to heart,
it's like expect nothing
and be pleasantly surprised.
- What were you gonna say?
- Because it's gotten to the point
where you know, every
YouTuber has this point
when they realize that
there's a point in your life,
when you realize, hey, your
mental health is really affected
by how well your videos do.
And that's really fucking unhealthy.
So like I had to get
to a point in YouTube,
where I just stopped looking at the views.
Like I had to stop looking at the views
and just focus on the content.
- That's hard to do.
- It is hard, it's a skill.
- It's just something I knew I had to do,
because we have this tool.
I don't know if we've
talked about this before,
but we have the tool on YouTube
where you upload a new video
and YouTube will tell you how
well it's performed out of 10.
That's your last 10 videos.
And to me, it's just a lose, lose game,
because you'd never-
- We should share the
Trash Taste one right now.
- It is, the most mind breaking mechanics.
- It is because what I've realized,
is that you lose most of the time, right?
Because if a video is
below five out of 10,
you feel like shit the entire day.
- I guess I'll die.
- Exactly, like with me me,
but like your day can literally be ruined
and it's fucking stupid
by knowing that your video
performed nine or 10.
- You feel like little
fucking fireworks animations,
if you are number one.
- [All] Yeah.
- (claps) Yes, yes but the thing is...
What I realize, is that if
it's like a four or five,
then you're just like, "Okay."
You don't feel good.
You feel relieved.
And that's just so unhealthy,
'cause that just means the only
time you actually feel good,
is when you get the number one or two.
Which statistically speaking,
you can't always get
the number one or two.
- And what's worse is like,
when you do get that number one,
the next thing you expect is,
"Well, the next video has
to be number one as well.
"I just have to keep one-upping myself
"and it never happens."
- So like, I always leave a
least like four or five days
before checking the views of my video.
That gives me enough time.
- Bro, you must survive
(indistinct) November easily then.
(all laughing)
- I guess before we wrap this up,
what's next for Aki Dearest,
what's the next plans?
What are you gonna do?
What are your goals?
- I'm working on the next case video.
I've been doing it.
I can't give you any
hint, I already told that.
- Would you say that you're
more like a short-term planner?
Like you don't really think
about like the like year
or two from now, you're like,
"I'm just thinking about what's
going on the next month."
- Yeah, I feel like it's
just good to just stay,
in the present 'cause that just shapes out
how your future is gonna be.
- Damn.
- That's a T-shirt.
- That's a T-shirt right there.
- I was not expecting something so deep.
- You've been watching Trash Taste.
- I'm pretty sure I've seen
people with chess pieces.
I say that.
- I don't know , I've been so stressed
over what could have been
or like, "What did I do?
"Oh man, I fucking did that yesterday."
When at the end of it,
it doesn't really matter.
So, I just feel like I
just have to fix it now.
- If like for every one thing I'm like,
"I could have done that."
I got like a hundred other
things where I'm like,
"Holy shit, I was so
lucky with this thing."
You win some, you lose some, right?
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- But I guess you wanna
do the outro, Joey.
Yeah, hey, if you have no idea who Aki is,
then as always, we'll
leave the links to socials
down in the description
and also, hey, look at all these patreons
who are living in the moment as well.
- Whoa, oh my God, Jesus Christ.
- It's viral.
- Who's your favorite patreon, Aki?
- This one, right?
- Jimmy.
- Jimmy got a point from where they are.
- Which one?
This one or that one?
- You, oh my God.
- This one, right?
(all laughing)
But if you wanna be pointed
out on screen blindly,
then make sure to go over to our patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter, the subreddit,
and hey, if you don't wanna see our faces,
follow us over on Spotify.
But yeah, thanks for
coming onto the show Aki.
- [Aki] Yeah, thank you.
- You finally come on,
so you can stop asking
the fuck (indistinct).
- When are we gonna
continue the anime show?
- No, we don't talk about that.
- We did not talk about that.
- We'd not talk about that show.
We have buried that show long ago.
- I didn't make the name by the way,
- I wonder who made the
name, The Anime Man.
- Joey's podcast prolonged.
- Couldn't tell you.
- But yeah, guys,
hopefully you enjoyed this
episode of Trash Taste
and I've been with the boys.
- Thank you very much, Aki, for coming.
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah, no worries, thanks for having me.
- It's been a long time coming.
- And we'll see you guys
in the next episode.
- Bye.
- And mic, bye mic.
(soft upbeat music)